Hi Lenol. Halt Tim. Heil Ehre. Alles Heil des Cordia.
Logbuch, Netzpolitik Nummer zweihundertundzwei. Soll uns mal keiner vorwerfen, wir würden hier nicht mit der Zeit gehen. Wir sind auf alles vorbereitet.
Ja, ja, natürlich, also wir wir wissen ja Bescheid. Ähm.
Wer werden dich wir.
Wer denn hier ähm die Hörer, wissen Offenscheid, wir hatten ähm sehr viel,
wir hatten langes Feedback. Es war noch nicht mal so viel, aber dafür länger. Also es war der dumme quasi die Scrollstrecke ist wahrscheinlich ist im am am oberen Ende der Skala die Anzahl der Kommentare noch nicht.
Du meinst, es wird lang kommentiert. Länglich wie man auch manchmal sagt.
Ne, da haben sich auch wirklich mehrere äh interessante äh Freds ergeben.
Die man aber so jetzt irgendwie schwer in Gänze wiedergeben kann. Ich habe eigentlich so überlegt, okay ich nehme da jetzt so Einzelpunkte raus und dann dann äußere ich mich nochmal hier dazu und dann kann ich hier vor versammelter Mannschaft erklären, warum meine Wahrheit viel gerechter ist als deine
und dann habe ich mir gedacht, das ist eigentlich irgendwie Unsinn, sowas zu machen. Deswegen ähm ich habe ein paar Themen
Punkte rausgenommen, die wir dich nochmal kurz ein bisschen ansprechen wollte. Und ansonsten kann ich euch nur einladen in diesen Kommentarfrade vorbeizukommen. Wir haben auch äh ein Novum. Ja, das, also es ist glaube ich tatsächlich das erste Mal passiert, dass wir ein
ein All-Caps-Kommentar bekommen haben. Das haben wir in zweihundert Sendungen echt nicht gehabt.
Ähm.
Also es ist noch bei Netzpolitik Org geschrieben habe
Artikel von Kai Biermann vor ein paar Jahren wo ich noch wo ich sagte, dass eben Podcasthörer die zivilisierteren Kommentare abgeben, was übrigens auch sich in diesem Fred,
wieder total zeigt. Ja, also absolut ähm äh respektvoller,
ordentlicher Umgang miteinander ähm.
Ohne irgendwie auf Personen einzudreschen oder so. Bin ich echt immer überrascht, selbst bei so einem Thema, was die Gemüter,
erhitzt. Eine Sache, die wieder aufkam,
Ist ein Thema, was wir schon vor ein paar Wochen mal gestreift haben. Das ist so diese Frage des pragmatisch Wählen. Ja? Ähm,
Willst du pragmatisch wählen, um Trump zu verhindern? Oder siehst du die gleiche Wahl als dann gebe ich Clinton eine Stimme und die kriegt sie nicht von mir.
Äh ich habe das unter strategische Wählen abgespeichert, das meinst du wahrscheinlich, ne?
Oder strategisch kann man wahrscheinlich auch sagen, ne? Also ähm und jetzt ist sie, ne, das ist natürlich kann ich mich da hinstellen und sagen ähm.
Ja, ich will nicht Clinton wählen, würde ich auch nicht wirklich wollen, ja? Hätte ich auch nur unter größeren Schmerzen gemacht
Aber wenn ich das nicht mache und mich dann eben so irgendwie quengelnd hinstelle und sage, nee, so, diese Wahl gefällt mir nicht. Äh ich möchte, mir gefallen beide Kandidaten, nicht? Da muss ich natürlich auch damit
äh leben, dass äh andere eben äh diese Wahl, dieses Wahlergebnis bestimmen und ich eben dann trotzdem mitzuverantworten habe,
Ähm wie das Ergebnis ausgefallen ist, ne?
Klar, eine andere Wahl wäre schön gewesen, ist aber leider ausgefallen. Ja und da kann man lange drüber quengeln, tue ich mit, ja? Nur am Wahltag äh ist es wie so oft im Leben. Äh du hast nicht die Wahl, die du haben möchtest und trotzdem
Handlungszwang und egal was du tust, Verantwortung am eigenen Handeln. Insofern kannst du dich dann eben jetzt nicht beschweren. Ein ähm.
Hat auch noch den Aspekt des Wahlsystems oder wenn man dann später eh nochmal draufkommt, deswegen, dass wir das hier mal raus.
Da kommen genau kommen wir nachher nochmal zu, wenn wir das Zimmer haben, aber dann gab's natürlich auch diesen äh diesen Aspekt, äh dass es eine Unterschied gibt, gehe zwischen der Popularwort und der Electric Vod. Und das ist,
Nach meinem letzten Kenntnisstand danach aussah, dass Hillary Clinton knapp mehr Stimmen hat. Also absolut, wenn man die.
Ich glaube, mittlerweile ist es schon ziemlich signifikant sogar. Dick bei eins Komma fünf Millionen oder so.
Okay, ich weiß da nicht, wie viel Prozent das jetzt wiederum sind. Also, sie hat auf jeden Fall die Meer immer noch haben, die Mehrheit der der Menschen, die gewählt haben,
Helibrück Clinton gewählt, aber aufgrund des Wahlmännersystemes ähm wird,
eben Donald Trump die Mehrheit im Electric haben.
Und das äh das ist natürlich eine wirkliche Krankheit eines solchen Wahlsystemes, dass noch viel größere Probleme hat, als dass nur ähm sage ich mal,
bestimmt das,
dass die, dass es eine Diskrepanz geben kann zwischen dem dokumentierten Willen der Wähler und dem äh sichergebenden Willen der Wähler. Du unterbrichst mich.
Ich könnte noch kurz die Zahlen, äh die aktuell nochmal nennen.
Ja, dann sag mal ganz kurz die Zahlen.
Also äh vierundsechzig Komma zwei Millionen zu zweiundsechzig Komma zwei Millionen. Ähm achtundvierzig Komma eins zu sechsundvierzig Komma sechs Prozent für Hillary Clinton.
So, das heißt du hast mehr Leute, die Hildebrücke Clinton gewählt haben, trotzdem aufgrund der Verteilung der Wahlmänner auf Staaten ein entsprechend anderes,
Ergebnis in der tatsächlichen Präsidentenwahl. Ähm.
Das ist sowieso schon mal das eine Problem, dieses Wahlsystem ist das andere Problem ist, dass in bestimmten,
starten völlig unerheblich ist, zu wählen, weil in jedem einzelnen Staat gilt ja The Winner Takes it or, das heißt eben so ein Staat hat so und so viele Wahlmänner,
Wahlpersonen, weil Frauen, Wahlwesen, könnte man eigentlich sagen, Wahlwesen, weil äh ein Staat hat so und so viel Wahlwesen und.
Alle gehen an den Kandidaten, der in,
diesen Start, den die Mehrheit hatte, ne? Und dadurch kommen diese Verzerrungen zustande. Gleichzeitig gibt es dann nämlich Staaten, in denen die nie anders wählen, ja? Also wo du einfach weißt, du hast an der Westküste, hast du
traditionell, da ist alles demokratisch, da brauchst du als Republikaner gar nicht zur Wahl zu gehen,
Und genauso hast du äh republikanische Staaten, wo du als Demokrat nicht zur Wahl zu gehen brauchst. Also fundamentale Kritik an diesem Wahlverfahren ist absolut angebracht, absolut angemessen. Ähm dummerweise steht das in der äh Verfassung. Es gibt aber ähm.
Im Prinzip niemand sagt, dass die Staaten ihren Wahlwesen aufoktruieren müssen,
so zu wählen, die unterliegen ja wieder ihrer ähm ihrem Gewissen.
Es gäbe also, man könnte dieses Wahlsystem beibehalten und einfach nur sagen, jeder,
jedes Wahlwesen verpflichtet sich dazu die Kandidaten zu wählen, die den Pophüller Vod haben. Das wäre so ein ähm.
Ein einfacher
ein einfacher Hack dafür und da gibt's gerade eine äh Initiative in den USA, dass das zu erreichen. Problem ist dann, dann wird die Politik am Ende über die Wahlleute gemacht
äh welche man da hinschickt, ne? Und dann hast du,
wahrscheinlich im Ergebnissen noch, da ist gar keine Wahl mehr, ne? Dann hast du irgendwie eine Volksabstimmung ohne bindende Wirkung und so ein paar Wahlwesen, die vorher äh von den einzelnen Parteien sehr vorsichtig da
platziert worden sind. Also schlechtes äh Wahlsystem,
Eine Änderung dieses Wahlsystems ist aber unwahrscheinlich, weil die Republikaner mehrmals davon profitiert haben, äh George Tabelle Busch, jetzt wieder Trump und jetzt sind hier gerade an der Macht, also werden die Republikaner wohl kaum sagen, oh, das ist aber ein blödes Wahlsystem, das sollte man.
Nicht nur die Republikaner haben davon Profite, also meines Wissens gab's beide Konstellationen schon. Also äh äh Tit for Ted äh am Ende, genau.
So. Aber natürlich ist gerade nach der Wahl wirklich der schlechteste Zeitpunkt sich über sowas auseinanderzusetzen und vor allem wenn du den Kongress voller Republikaner hast und ähm den Republikanerpräsidenten. Nun.
Entscheidend ist natürlich trotzdem ach so,
Genau, diese den den Staaten, in denen es eigentlich völlig egal ist, ob du wählen gehst, gegenüber stehen natürlich die Swings der Aids, äh in denen es eben nicht egal ist, wo du ein Zünglein an der Waage bist und wo dieser Staat mit seinen, mit seiner Anzahl Wahlwesen.
Die Wahl signifikant beeinflusst. Auf diese Staaten haben sich natürlich dann auch die Kandidaten konzentriert. So, Halloween Clinton hat jetzt nicht eine großartige,
Kalifornientournee gemacht. Die hat natürlich ihre Bemühungen auf die Swing States gelegt. Ebenso ähm Donald Trump.
Trotzdem de facto.
Haben in den relevanten Stellen, also alles, was ich jetzt sage, ist quasi, ne? Bezieht sich ja gar nicht mehr auf den Popular Worte, sondern auf die relevanten Staaten, die in der Lage sind, das äh das Ergebnis einer US-Wahl überhaupt zu beeinflussen. Ähm,
haben sie es offen, äh haben die Demokraten es nicht geschafft? Ähm.
Genug Leute zur Wahl zu mobilisieren, denn was wir auch sehen ist, dass die,
Absolute Stimme der Republikaner, die absolute Stimmanzahl der Republikaner über die vergangenen Wahlen,
Im Vergleich zu der absoluten Wahlstimmenanzahl der Demokraten sehr viel weniger,
abweicht. Dass dies eigentlich nahezu konstant, ja? Natürlich sind das nicht immer exakte gleiche Anzahl Personen, aber du hast so irgendwie das Panel sich so bei dieser Zahl ein. Und am Ende wird die Wahl offenbar,
Dadurch entschieden, wie viele Personen die Demokraten in der Lage sind, zu mobilisieren. Wie gesagt, diese Betrachtung ist ein bisschen unzulässig jetzt, weil sie auf den Popular-Wort geht und eigentlich entscheidend ja aber nur die ähm die Swing States sind.
Aber man kann festhalten. Die Donald Trump hat die Wahl nicht gewonnen, weil viele Menschen.
Auf einmal mehr Menschen als sonst gesagt haben, ich wähle Republikaner, sondern er hat die Wahl primär deshalb gewonnen, weil mehr Menschen gesagt haben, ich wähle nicht Demokraten und wähle unten
eben unter Umständen gar nicht. Also genau dieses ich wähle nicht Hillary Clinton, weil schlechter Mensch.
Und und irgendwie schlechte Wahl, diese Wahl gefällt mir nicht, ich lasse zurückgehen.
So, aber jetzt kommt der spannende Teil, wie hat die Trump-Kampagne das geschafft, dass das passiert ist.
Und die entscheidende Rolle spielt da eine der entscheidenden Rollen spielt dabei der Steve Bennon, der hat zweitausendzwölf,
Die rechtspopulistische Seite Breitbart News übernommen, die wir in der letzten Sendung auch schon ähm äh erwähnt hatten.
Die jetzt auch angekündigt hat, nach Deutschland kommen zu wollen.
Genau die jetzt sagt so oh super, das hat ja hier prima gekla,
auch spannend, ne? Genau vier Jahre, ne? So ungefähr so in in diesem Zeitraum planst du natürlich auch 'ne Kampagne, ne? Der hat dieses Breitband übernommen und wurde kurz nach der Wahl, also es ist eine wirklich eine üble Hetze, ich komm da gleich noch ein bisschen mehr drauf. Nach der Wahl ist er jetzt
Counciler to the President und damit der Chefstratege und Rang höchste Berater von Donald Trump geworden.
Und was Breitbart gemacht hat, ähm wird könnte man oder wird bezeichnet als eine,
quasi eine unfavor Rebility Strategy. Also die haben genau dieses Ergebnis.
Ähm im im Blick gehabt, dass sie sagen, wir werden nicht Donald Trump großartig promoten, wir werden einfach nur dafür sorgen, dass die Leute nicht Hillary Clinton wählen.
Weil's den wahrscheinlich auch letztlich nicht unbedingt um Trump ging, sondern um also kann man also ich weiß man nicht.
Da kann man also ich würde gerne noch so ein bisschen mehr über diese Strategie äh reden, ja? Die haben also einfach dieses es reicht und Lügenpresse.
So lange rumgepoltert, bis ähm bis eben niemand mehr Clinton weht, ich übertreibe jetzt, ne? Und das haben sie natürlich gerne auch mit mit Lügen getan, immer mal wieder,
Trump gleichzeitig.
Hat sich irgendwie unscharf und inhaltsleer gehalten und hat immer wieder alles unser Gegenteil behauptet, ja? Du konntest den auf nix festnageln, außer auf diese Mauer und die finden viele Amerikaner halt tatsächlich gut.
Sorry. Ähm so jetzt ähm.
Ob wenn sie die ja schon längst haben.
Die haben sich schon längst, aber wir wollen sie jetzt noch eine haben oder mehr. So, dann,
Dann hat er den einen zweiten Menschen dabei gehalten, gehabt, das ist der Winton Hall. Das ist ein ehemaliger äh Trump Ghostwriter. Der hat quasi die,
Die Anti Clinton Stories dieser Seite ähm so richtig orchestriert mit so einer Art ähm,
Mit so einer Art Drehbuch. Also er hat sich wirklich hingesetzt und gesagt, ich möchte, äh
In diesem Medium erstmal die Geschichte haben, dann soll die da platziert werden und dann soll sie irgendwann in den Mainstream-Medien sein und dann können wir als Breitbart darüber berichten. Das heißt, sie haben gezielt Stories langziert
gestil äh gezielt aus Stories recherchiert und die platziert. Und die diese Strategie haben sie selber benannt als
also du ähm verankerst dich mit mit den Dingen, über die du berichtest. Bei der Linken.
Und zerrst dann im weiteren Verlauf der Story in Richtung rechts,
Also du fischt nach unzufriedenen. Du säßt dieses ähm ne, das.
Genau meinst du mit äh Ankern im linken.
Du beginnst die Story bei den Linken, bei den Linken unzufriedenen? Im Spektrum, ja? Also, na ja, man muss dazu sagen, also bei denen ist links.
Arbeitermilieu meinst du jetzt.
Nee, weil die meinen mit links sowas wie ähm New York Times, ne? Jeder andere wird das Mainstream-Mess äh Mainstream-Presse nennen, aber die äh sagen halt, das ist ja die linke Schmielpresse, ne? New York Times kommen wir gleich auch nochmal,
drauf zurück. Also du gehst dein, deinen Storyverlauf ist immer so geschrieben, dass du,
Bei den Unzufriedenen oder bei den oder Links von den unzufriedenen anfängst und im weiteren Verlauf die ganze Story nach rechts ziehst.
Und ähm bis das Ganze halt bis hin zu den äh bis zu den Rassisten, die ja jetzt auch äh die Trump-Wahl feiern, auch da kommen wir nochmal zu. Das heißt, die ganze
Idee von Breitbandnews war, äh Leute provozieren und aufbringen gegen das Establishment, gegen Hillary Clinton.
Und dann diese ganze Wut einfach nur hinter Trump zu kanalisieren und das hat großartig geklappt, das siehst du ja jetzt auch an vielen Stellen. Ähm,
Zusätzlich hat dieser Benne, das war nur ein Arm seiner Strategie, einer der Analysten, der sich den Ben seit Jahren anschaut, äh, berichtet, dass so ein bisschen äh nett das so ein bisschen wie Doktor Jackle und Mister Hydes, also die Mister Hyde Strategie, ne, so richtig dirty bei den
dort hier die Leute zu manipulieren oder so, ne? Auch mit Fake News arbeiten. Zusätzlich hat er das Government Accountability Institut
Und das hat ein äh Buch rausgebracht, Clinton Cash.
Ähm und zwar genau zweitausendfünfzehn als Clinton losgelegt ist mit ihrer Kampagne, die wussten ja, dass Clinton das machen würde.
Wie heißt das Institut? Government.
Ähm Government Accountability Instit.
Und das Buch Clinton Cash ist tatsächlich einfach eine ordentliche Recherche zu irgendwelchen Spendengeschichten und Verstrickungen, die die Clintons hatten. Völlig in Ordnung, total. Also ähm ne, da die Dinge, die da drin stehen, so,
Scheint der Tenor zu sein, sind einfach sauber reduziert. Äh äh recherchiert. Sauber recherchiert und zutreffend, ja? Und das wurde natürlich auch sofort in den Mainstream-Medien, linke Presse, ne? Also ähm,
aufgefasst und äh da gibt's zu, dann hast du dann irgendwie Großspender äh der Clintons gefallen, Freundschaften und so weiter aufgedeckt.
Und ähm das Spannende oder die der Kern dieser Strategie ist, dass sie nämlich in mit diesem Buch da schaden,
wo die Clintons aufbauen wollen,
und ihr Wahlkampf, ihre Wahlkampfstrategie wieder genau nicht darauf ausgerichtet ist, inhaltliche Positionen gegenüberzustellen, ähm.
Sondern einfach nur die Person in Misskredit zu bringen. Und genau aus dem Grund haben sie auch keine,
eigenen inhaltlichen, sinnvollen Strategien präsentiert. Und das jetzt irgendwie wenige Tage nach der Wahl Steve Bennon äh als Councler äh benannt wird, äh ist natürlich jetzt kein Zufall, ne? Die haben seit Jahren zusammengearbeitet
Ähm,
auf das Themengebiet Fake News werden wir glaube ich nochmal im anderen Rahmen eingehen, aber auch da gab's siehst du, die spiegeln genau das wieder. Ähm.
Gab's eine schöne Studie, die sich einige der Fake News im Vorlauf der Wahl angeschaut haben, so an einem Tag. Und da waren dann irgendwie so vier,
erlogene Storys gegen Clinton und eine pro Trump und das spiegelt auch schon ungefähr dieses Verhältnis wieder, was die ähm,
Was sie auch im Breitbad eben immer wieder spielen. Ähm die Pro Trump war die Fehlmeldung, äh dass der Papst Trump entdor,
und diese diese Fake News sind immer so schön ähm so schön einfach gestrickt, dass sie so Social Media kompatibel sind. Ein weiterer ähm,
Ausspruch von diesen Strategen ist, faktge, und das ist richtig ähm,
das kann man sich echt nur merken. Die haben also im Prinzip also unter Fakt fällt bei denen auch ähm Nonfacts.
Und dann sind die mit Openien, sind die relativ klein geblieben erstmal. Immer erst nachher. Die haben erkannt, dass du Meinungen nicht darüber steuerst, was du wozu sagst,
sondern darüber, was berichtet wird.
Und diese ähm diese Strategie ist auf den, auf einen Nährboden gefallen, der die Politik der letzten Jahre und Jahrzehnte.
Umfasst die natürlich sämtliches Vertrauen verspielt hat, da wollen wir uns gar nichts vormachen. Insofern gab's auch einige ähm Kommentare, die irgendwie den den Eindruck erweckt und wir werden jetzt hier große äh Mainstream-Politik-Fans. Ähm das fand ich dann auch ähm,
Das fand ich lustig, die müssen wahrscheinlich die Sendung noch nicht so viel gehört haben. Ähm.
Und natürlich hat diese existente Politik den das,
das Vertrauen verspielt, nur keiner scheint zu merken, dass Trump das Vertrauen noch viel weniger verdient als Hirry Clinton.
Und da passiert nämlich jetzt das, was man Normalisierung nennt, nämlich,
nachträglich diese Wahl zu verklären zu etwas, was Leute gewollt hät.
Das Volk hat gesprochen, sie wollen Donald Trump als ihren Präsidenten haben, dann wird so beschwichtigt und rationalisiert, was Donald Trump tut. Obwohl allen klar ist, dass der
Die Politik noch nicht mal definiert hat, ne? Also du hast diesen, du hast diesen
wirklich wahnsinnigen an der Macht und dann sitzen jetzt schon so Leute bereit, die jetzt na ja, jetzt müssen wir erstmal schauen, jetzt müssen wir
erstmal ne begutachten und und analysieren und und irgendwie unserem äh unsere Anerkennung dafür aussprechen, wie wie was für ein geschickter Wahlkampfstratege Donald Trump ist. Donald Trump ist
kein Geschicker Wahlkampfstratege, ne? Es ist äh es war auch noch nie ein Präsident ein geschickter Wahlstrand Wahlkampfstratege, die Leute, die diese Wahlkämpfe orchestrieren, die Campaign-Manager, die Leute, die nachher
Counciler sind, das sind die, das sind die Strategen dahinter und da sind äh sicherlich
sehr kluge Cap Köpfe, unter anderem eben dieser Stephen Bennon und der äh Winon.
Die Leute, die uns jetzt beschwichtigen und das schönreden, dass es alles äh das was da geschehen würde, ne. Die verfolgen interessanterweise oft genau ähnliche Strategien,
nämlich die ganze Zeit zu erklären, wie die Welt nämlich wirklich ist, aufklären, ne, dann hast du auch sehr schöne äh Worte, die bei solchen Medien dann oft vorkommen, ne, die dann sowieso.
Kritisch. Äh dann hast du diese ganze Querdenkerfront und so, ne? Die eine und die dann alle so wir
wie es richtig, wie es wirklich ist und wir sind alternativmedien, da gab's auch übrigens einen schönen Kommentar, der uns kritisierte, wie wer nicht ausreichend gute ähm Alternativmedien.
Wir wären kein Alternat.
Ausreichend gutes Alternativmedium. Ja, weil ich glaube, dass also ich glaube, dass der Begriff Alternativmedium.
Bei vielen genau damit verbunden ist, dass du so wir berichten aber jetzt anders,
Wir erklären jetzt, wie das wirklich ist, die anderen stecken alle unter einer Decke und verarschen euch. Passt auf und so, ne? Und und in Wirklichkeit ist das aber so und und Trump gar nicht so schlecht. Ähm da gibt's auch diesen,
dieser Fatz Autor, der irgendwann mal rausgeflogen ist und ein Buch geschrieben hat, wie heißt der nochmal? Ähm, Udo Ulfkotte, Udo Ulfkotte, so.
Also bei der sind ja schon so einige rausgeflogen und haben da ein Buch geschrieben. Also.
Aber nein, aber genau, also dieser Ulfkotte, ne, der jetzt.
Verschwörungshigh nieder.
Ja, der ist dann jetzt irgendwie bei äh bei der der veröffentlicht dann im Kopfverlag und ähm.
Bei Pegida.
Schrift weg, der solche solche Leute, ne? Und der der hat ja dann irgendwie, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie das Buch hieß. Ähm,
Sowas ungefähr wie wie korrupte Journalisten uns alle verarschen. Ich weiß es, weil ich war mal bei der Faz. Ähm diese Leute.
Kaufte Journalisten.
Das sind also diese Leute, die jetzt gerade diese Normalisierung betreiben. Und das alles in einem, ich finde das sehr amüsant, mir das anzuschauen, weil heute liest du oder lese ich, weiß nicht, ob du das gelesen hast.
Auf der einen Nachrichtenseite Trump sagt zu Klimawandel Hü und auf der anderen Nachrichtenseite Trump sagt zum Klimawandel Hot, der fährt nämlich diese Strategie, einfach nicht greifbar zu sein und alles und sein Gegenteil zu behaupten
einfach weiter. Also es gab ja, es gibt ja offenbar Leute, die erwarten.
Dass er sich jetzt irgendwie positionieren muss und die Würde des Amtes würde ihn jetzt schon in irgendeiner Form wieder zur Resort bringen.
Stattdessen haut er auch äh gerade in dieser Phase, also wo wirklich nochmal eine besondere Aufmerksamkeit ist und halt auch auf,
alle wieder ein, so, also in keinerlei Hinsicht äh dieses eigentlich allgemeine übliche wie Partysen verhalten.
Macht keine also hat glaube ich seit einem halben Jahr keine Pressekonferenzen mehr gegeben.
Hat jetzt ein YouTube-Video veröffentlicht.
Und mache das halt jetzt irgendwie über seinen eigenen Kanal sozusagen. Macht ein YouTube-Video mit hier irgendwie, ich bin jetzt hier der Großführer und erzähle euch jetzt mal äh was Sache ist, ne? Und vor allem.
Okay, da kommen wir ja wahrscheinlich eh gleich noch drauf. Was da alles mit äh drin ist, aber also wir sehen auch einen neuen.
Kommunikationsstil, der in gewisser Hinsicht wahrscheinlich eine Fortführung dieses Wahlkampfes. Wir werden uns und dieser Wahlkampf, der alle schon seit auf dem Zahnfleisch laufen lassen und ich glaube, wenn's irgendwie einen großen Wunsch in den letzten Wochen gab, dann war das dieses, kann das bitte endlich mal zu Ende sein
und ich glaube, dass das können wir uns komplett abschminken. So geht das jetzt weiter. Das ist jetzt ein Dauer.
Das ist genau das, was ähm.
Wirklich ich auch in der letzten Sendung schon angesprochen habe, was beängstigend ist und was äh uns auf ein Feld führt, was sehr, sehr, sehr gefährlich ist.
Ähm und das macht mir wirklich Sorgen, insbesondere auch natürlich dann äh auf Deutschland im Bezug auf Deutschland. Und,
ärgerlich ist, dass es also diese Lügen,
Wirklich zu seiner Marke zu machen, ne? Wir äh erklären euch jetzt, wie es wirklich ist und wir sind alternativ und kritisch und so weiter,
sorry, das geht ein bisschen zu weit, ja. Äh man kann ähm.
Alles scheiße außer uns.
Ja, ne, alle Lügen, alle Lügen, außer wir. Und hier auch so, hier haben wir eine kleine Lügenstory verbreiten, ja, ja, kann man ja mal machen. Versteht ihr keine Ironie.
Also das.
War ja nicht ernst gemeint.
Und das ist übrigens auch, möchte ich jetzt mal ganz klar sagen, wie warum ich ich habe in meinem Leben nichts anderes gemacht als Alternativmedien,
Im Sinne von alternative Veröffentlichungsform, alternative Themenschwerpunktsetzung, aber weder bei Netzpolitik Org noch bei Lokbuch Netzpolitik, pflegen wir diesen ähm,
Diesen Charakter von äh die Lügen alle und das System ist korrupt und völlig im Arsch. Und jetzt aber mal wirklich und wir brauchen einen neuen Führer und das muss alles in Trümmern liegen
Das ist ähm auch selten zu Ende gedacht, wenn Leute sich äh wenn Leute solche Strategien verfahren und wird dann eben auch zurecht ähm.
Aber erzeugt Klicks, erzeugt Aufmerksamkeit und das ist halt auch ein parallel dazulaufender Trend, den ihr sicherlich alle auch sehr gut kennt.
In dieser neu geschaffenen Netz äh Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie, ja? Geilen sich doch einige daran auf, geradezu so einem Suchtverhalten.
Ich brauche Aufmerksamkeit. Ich kriege sonst nicht genug Aufmerksamkeit, ich brauche diese Aufmerksamkeit und dann ist halt irgendein bestimmten Punkt auch egal, wie man diese Aufmerksamkeit bekommt,
irgendwann man testet dann vielleicht das ein oder andere aus und stellt dann fest so ah wenn ich irgendwie so und so schreie ja dann erzeugt das am meisten Aufmerksamkeit,
die Konsequenzen daraus dann natürlich nochmal eine ganz andere Frage und ich habe so den Eindruck, die stellen sich halt zu wenig Leute, ne? Und,
was weiß ich, sehen sich dann vielleicht auch noch in so einem Auftrag der der Weltenrettung auf einmal äh gebunden. Da kann man sich auch schnell äh einen einreden und die Konsequenzen dieses Handels, denke ich mal, werden hier zu wenig,
berücksichtigt. Das ist äh ein Problem und äh ich weiß nicht genau, wie viele,
ähm Brandstifter in dieser Hinsicht äh so ein Land, so eine Gesellschaft verträgt, sicherlich äh nicht sehr viele.
Und die wandern ja dann auch, also da wir haben jetzt ja den Ulfkotte so rausgenommen. Da gibt's ja noch ganz andere, ne? Also irgendwie Elsässer und wie sie alle heißen, auch viele Horst Mahler, jetzt kein Journalist, ne, aber ist das beste beste Beispiel für jemanden, der halt irgendwie von der,
Von dieser linken Sache System, Kritik und so, ne. Ähm weil ganz hart nach rechts gesteuert hat, ne? Und nur weil jemand das also,
Systemkrit.
Die Leute, die es mit Geschichte nicht Gänse haben, Horst Maler damals mit Otto Shili und äh.
Nee, warte mal, äh ich bin mir äh Horst Maler ähm hatte auch mit Otto Schiri zu tun, aber der war eigentlich raff. Der saß auch im Knast dafür.
Ne, da war der der war Verteidiger.
Äh ja, aber äh.
Der war Anwalt.
Der rote Armee Fraktion,
sagte sich neunzehnhundertfünfundsiebzig vom Terrorismus los. Er erlangte erreichte neunzehnhundertachtundachtzig seine Wiederzulassung als Anwalt. Ehemaliger Angehöriger des SDS und Mitbegründer der Rot-Armee-Fraktion. Also viel radikal.
Kann's ja kaum sein.
Aber trotzdem halt so.
Diese Welt irgendwie und dann komplett äh rübermarschiert. Also so eine so eine so eine Hauptsache dagegen Fraktionen, wo dann auch links und rechts keinerlei Bedeutung mehr hat, ja? Äh links und rechts,
Ist ohnehin glaube ich ein sehr problematischer Begriff,
ist auch so ein bisschen verpönt, ja? Wir erinnern uns, da gab's auch so eine netzorientierte Partei, die sich auch irgendwie äh für eine gute Idee hielt, sich da sozusagen komplett äh frei von zu machen und zu sagen, ja, wir wir sind ja wieder links nach rechts, wir sind ja vorne. Ähm.
Ich glaub aber, dass dass diese Verankerung schon,
Sehr sinnvoll ist, um sich ja, um einfach sagen wir mal den, den Grundhinor der eigenen äh äh politischen Gestaltung auch äh klarzumachen äh ohne damit auch automatisch einen,
Lagerverordnung, unmittelbar zu assozieren. Die wird natürlich dann schnell daraus gemacht. Aber dieses Ganze, das System ist scheiße und es muss sich was ändern. Ding ist halt,
Von diesen politischen Dingen vollkommen befreit, das ist eigentlich eine unpolitische Bewegung.
Und und ich meine, das ist etwas, was auch viele Leute fühlen und genau genau da werden ja auch viele Leute jetzt gerade abgeholt, sowohl von Rechten, als auch von Linken
Auf dem, wenn von dem Punkt das System ist Scheiße, geht's immer noch in zwei Richtungen und manche meinen rechts und rechts kann man nicht verwechseln.
Wäre ich ein Iltum.
Ich wusste, ich hab's nicht ohne Ernst Janne durch die Nummer. So, jetzt kommen wir aber mal zu der zweiten Möglichkeit, wie diese Wahl entschieden worden sein könnte,
Wir haben jetzt diese äh Breitbartgeschichte und äh und äh armes Amerika-Lügenpresseding.
Dann haben wir die Normalisierung von von diesen von diesem äh Verhalten, was was denke ich eine sehr gefährliche Rolle ist, die Mainstream und Alternativmedien nicht spielen sollten,
Und jetzt haben wir Alex Haldermann auf einmal in den News Helderman ähm wird er, glaube ich, ausgesprochen. Ähm Universe jetzt hier auf dem Mishigon.
Ähm da der Leiter des äh Center for Computersoße in Society und ähm echt mal also ich habe das Glück ihn auch mal kennengelernt zu haben. Ein ziemlich schlauer Kopf,
Was haben die rausgefunden, Tim.
Die haben rausgefunden, dass äh zumindest im Staate Visconsin ist äh interessante Abweichungen gibt bei den Wahlergebnissen in verschiedenen Bezirken.
Mathematikern dürfte das klar sein, dass wenn man sich halt solche Ergebnisse anschaut, dass sie natürlich nicht alle gleich sind
ja? Aber dass sie natürlich in bestimmten Regionen schon Trends abzeichnen und dass man ähm abweichendes Verhalten über die Zeit und äh über die Region ähm,
schon an gewissen auffällig über das man da auch gewisse Auffälligkeiten feststellen kann, so ist denn welche gibt. Und die,
Auffälligkeit, die Ihnen hier ins Auge gefallen ist, ist das, dass die Wahlbezirke in den Elektronikvoting zum Einsatz kommt.
Anstatt halt einer PayPal-Balance-Methode, ich meine, es gibt in USA,
so viele unterschiedliche ähm Arten und Weisen abzustimmen. Äh hier geht's konkret um Wahlcomputer,
Dass in diesen Stimmbezirken Trump ungefähr sieben Prozent mehr,
Stimmen erhalten hat, als in den Bezirken, die eben das nicht haben,
Gut, sieben Prozent liegt jetzt erstmal nicht viel, ist allerdings ähm für so eine statistische Wahrscheinlichkeit schon relativ äh stark und wie ich das,
bekommen habe ähm geht es sozusagen für alle.
Und ähm ja, das Ganze ist jetzt in dem Sinne auch noch nicht öffentlich, der Bericht, den wir hier zitieren,
ähm ist zwar verhältnismäßig konkret, was die Zahlen betrifft, nur ist das Ganze derzeit äh mutmaßlich,
quasi noch auf dieser Beratungsebene des Clintonteams äh in Diskussionen, die sich ja quasi jetzt vor die Frage gestellt sieht, ob das Anhaltspunkte sind, die ähm es ähm.
Wo es dann geboten wäre, hier die Wahl auch anzufechten. Das ist eine Entscheidung, die relativ bald fallen muss, weil
ähm die Widerspruchsfrist gegen die Wahl jetzt hier am Freitag, also äh ab heute in zwei Tagen beziehungsweise ein paar anderen Staaten, die gegebenenfalls ja auch noch,
in Frage kommen würden, äh nächste Woche oder so ablaufen,
Ja und äh für uns ist das natürlich ein Thema, ganz klar hatten wir ja nie auch schon mehrfach besprochen. Was das natürlich genau etwas ist,
unabhängig davon, ob das jetzt tatsächlich auf Basis einer Manipulation stattgefunden hat.
Selbstverständlich könnte es sein, dass in diesen Bezirken wo zufällig äh Wahlcomputer zum Einsatz kommen, auch Leute,
Trump einfach geiler finden oder vermehrt zur Wahl gegangen sind, weil sie denken so, ah ja, mit dem Wahlcomputer abzustimmen, das ist ja so einfach, dann
Ja, dann dann kann ich auch meine Stimme äh abgeben,
nur üblicherweise würde sich das eben statistisch vielleicht in einer höheren Wahlbeteiligung aber nicht unbedingt einem anderen Ergebnis niederschlagen.
Ja, nehmen wir mal an.
Dass hier äh was im Busch ist. Jetzt haben wir eine Wahl gehabt, die extrem von ähm Berichten über Hacking-Attacken geprägt war, insbesondere die äh,
E-Mail äh äh Attacken gegen E-Mail-Systeme des äh demokratischen Nationalkomitees,
Clinton natürlich auch nochmal im besonderen Wiki-League-Veröffentlichung und so weiter. Also das, dass dieses Elektronikhacking gegen Wahl mit der Wahl in Verbindung stehende,
Entitäten stattgefunden hat, ist hier ganz offensichtlich,
Uns war schon immer äh unsere Position hier darauf hinzuweisen, dass natürlich Wahlcomputer an der Stelle ein besonderes Problem sind, denn.
Stimmen die mit dem Wahlcomputer abgegeben wurden sind,
Per Definition einfach nicht überprüfbar. Weil es gibt ein paar Leute, die immer noch den Traum anhängen, müsste alles gehen und,
Wenn man eine tolle Software und Open Sourcen, was nicht alles im Einsatz bringen würde ähm,
Na, sorry ist äh leider nicht so. Wir haben's halt einfach hier damit mit einem nicht beobachtbaren System zu tun. Es äh endet dann irgendwie alles so in in den Formeln der Quantenmechanik. Äh.
Weiß jetzt auch nicht ganz genau, welche Systeme hier konkret zum Einsatz gekommen sind, aber alle dieser äh Systeme haben halt einfach das Problem, dass sie im Prinzip ähm nicht belegbar sind.
Könnte sein, dass hier Paper Ballets nochmal sozusagen als als Belegzettel auch noch äh ausgedruckt werden. Das gäbe vielleicht die Möglichkeit, tatsächlich nachzuzählen, wo man sich dann natürlich auch gleich fragen kann
wenn es diese Möglichkeit gibt, warum zählt man nicht gleich das Papier, weil warum irgendwie auf Computer äh verlassen, wenn's äh auch anders geht,
Das äh ist spannend zu sehen und.
Denke ich mal, ist auch wieder ein klares Signal, äh warum solche Wahlcomputer einfach eine ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz schlechte Idee sind.
Selbst wenn sie eben, also.
Sie werden auch deshalb eine schlechte Idee, wenn das jetzt nicht, wenn das jetzt dieser Verdacht sich nicht erhärtet, ne, also muss man auch noch dazu sagen, ähm die haben diesen ein
Anhaltspunkt, die
möchten das genauer untersuchen. Dafür muss Clinton offiziell die Wahl anzweifeln, dann werden sie dafür bestellt werden oder werden Experten dafür bestellt werden, diese Wahl auf Manipula Pulation zu prüfen und dann können kann ja trotzdem noch rauskommen, dass es keine Anzeichen gab.
Oder zumindest kann rauskommen, dass sie keine Anzeichen finden können, weil das ist das System ihnen gar nicht erlaubt, Anzeichen zu finden.
Aber genau, allein deshalb willst du's schon nicht machen, weil du eben eine Anzweiflung der Wahl im Zweifelsfall nicht oder eine Nachprüfung der Wahl nicht auf auf
ernst zu nehmende Wege machen kannst. Also da werden wir mal sehen
dieser Bericht ist relativ neu, es gibt auch noch den die offizielle Untersuchung noch gar nicht, es ist jetzt nur klar, dass die direkt auf das Klinkenteam ein ähm wirken und sagen, bitte, bitte, bitte.
Erreicht diesen Widerspruch ein, weil wenn die Frist verstrichen ist, äh dann ist die Frist verstrichen.
Kannst du auch nur eine Wahl kannst halt nur vierzehn Tage zurückgehen lassen. Kein Sale ist ja auch irgendwie, ne? Musst ja auch irgendwie mal die AGBs lesen.
Ich wäre auch nicht überrascht, wenn äh unter Trumps Egide die Zahl von Wahlcomputern noch weiter nach oben geht,
das passt äh super auch noch zu der anderen äh Technik, die er unter Gary Mandring bekannt ist, dass man quasi auch sich die Stimmen äh Vorteile in bestimmten Bereichen allein dadurch erhält, dass man eben die Bezirke, die Wahlbezirke entsprechend zuschneidet.
Und das ist alles nicht gut, ist äh auch bedrückend, dass da keine äh offene Diskussion äh gibt in USA oder zumindest keine die in irgendeiner Form nennenswerte Unterstützung unterhält. Wir können uns hier noch äh von Glück.
Ähm können sehr glücklich sein und können von Glück reden, dass wir zumindest derzeit eine einen kompletten Ausschluss,
Computern haben, Kraft der Entscheidung des Bundesverfassungsgerichts, die so hohe Hürden aufgestellt hat, die von Waldcomputer.
Unserer Meinung nach nicht erfüllt werden kann und so dass wir
quasi von diesem System noch äh befreit sind, zumindest war's Bundestagswahl, Landtagswahlen betrifft, ich muss immer wieder schmunzeln, wenn dann hier unsere Parteien auf ihren Delegiertentagen auch schön auf die Tasse drücken,
da gab's auch vor kurzem auch nochmal einen Ausfall, war das bei den Grünen neulich.
Wo sie dann irgendwie das System funktionierte dann nicht und dann mussten sie dann doch nochmal irgendwie auf Papier zurückgehen und so weiter. Also da ist auch so ein, so ein Glaube,
Ja, dass das eine tolle Idee ist und da kann ich nur nochmal nachschieben, liebe Parteien.
Benutzt keine Wahlcomputer. Ja, es ist äh es ist vielleicht ja so toll, ja, aber.
Ich glaub gerade gerade bei dem Security Level, der auf so einem Parteitag stattfindet
der dürfte nicht sehr groß sein, da werden wahrscheinlich so am Nachmittag irgendwo vielleicht noch zwei Tage vorher irgendwelche äh Windows-PCs vom vom vom Lastwagen äh
geschoben, ja? Noch vielleicht noch ein Service direkt geschoben oder vielleicht hat man das Ganze auch schon zentral in seiner Cloud, aber.
Das Maß an Zugriff auf diese Systeme dürfte sehr hoch sein. Gar nicht mal jetzt durch böse Hacker äh von außen, ja, sondern,
Einfach so von Leuten, die so in dem Apparat sind, die damit zuständig sind und die irgendwie festgestellt haben, so ach so, okay, wie heißt die Datei? Ach ja, hier Resalz Punkt äh,
ja
merkt halt keiner, ja, auf welche äh Tasten gedrückt wurde, beziehungsweise was der Computer am Ende für Ergebnisse liefert und weiß nicht, ob ihr wirklich Bock habt darauf, euch äh einzulassen.
Deswegen halt deswegen hat doch Trump auch bei Melania kritisch nachgeprüft, wie sie wählt.
Deniz hätte blinkt nach links.
Ähm dann haben wir letz.
Linken muss man immer im Blick haben.
Wir haben letzte Woche gesagt, wir wollen mal gucken, was Trump jetzt macht. Ähm für die meisten Teile kann man sagen
alles unser Gegenteil. Ähm heute Morgen Nachrichtenseiten aufgemacht und auf der einen steht äh Trump äh leugnet den Klimawandel weiterhin. Hier ist seine Politik. Auf der anderen steht Trump äh deutet an, dass es vielleicht doch Klimawandel geben könnte.
Dass der Mensch unter Umständen vielleicht etwas.
Könnte eventuell eine kleine Rolle gehabt haben.
Ähm aber er hat ein hat ein YouTube-Video veröffentlicht ähm und äh da hat er gesagt, was er jetzt machen wird. So, also was er auf jeden Fall machen wird. So, ne, da hat er sich jetzt wirklich mal festgelegt mit. Wobei, wie gesagt,
bis zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt gibt es kein anderes YouTube-Video, in dem in dem er das Gegenteil behauptet. Also was wir jetzt gerade äh hier.
Er sagte, also er will das Trendspacific Partnership absagen, ähm also das ist ein.
Das ist so T-Tipp für mit dem Pazifik.
T-Tipp für den Pazifik. Ähm und da möchte er dann bilaterale Vereinbarungen statt Freihandel haben. Ähm,
Make China Great Again. Äh es war so ungefähr die Antwort der ähm äh der der Weltökonomie, die also sagte, ja okay, mach mal, das ist super, da wird China sich freuen.
Das ist wirklich so wunderbar absurd, weil ich ich verstehe auch überhaupt gar nicht, was den Trump da an der Stelle so reitet. Ja, also ich meine, er will jetzt sozusagen protektionistisch auftreten und äh.
Ja ja das ist das was die Leute wollen ne? Also.
Und TP ist halt eigentlich genau das gewesen.
Das ist das der so Leute, ja aber das verstehen die Leute nicht.
Nee, ähm er auch nicht.
Also es verstehe ja, das ist aber auch wirklich schwer, also Weltwirtschaft ist wirklich ein schweres kompliziertes Thema, ne? Verstehe ich auch nicht, deswegen haben wir auch nicht Lokbuchwirtschaftspolitik, sondern Lokbuchnetzpolitik ist ein bisschen einfacher. Für mich zumindest,
Ähm dann möchte er Arbeitsplatzvernichtende Einschränkungen auf dem Energiemarkt abbauen. Aha, ja okay, Arbeitstag zwar nicht eine Einschränkung, wollen wir natürlich alle nicht. Ja und dann sagt er, okay.
Insbesondere möchte er Clean Cole fördern und und äh Schiefergasförderung. Klingt geil, ne? Denkst du ja, warum war das denn jemals eingeschränkt, ne? Na ja, Schiefergasförderung ist das sogenannte Fracking, wo du irgendwelches Gift in den Boden pumpst,
wo wo eben die Leute dann den Leuten fallen die Haare aus, aber die Energiepreise sinken, gibt mehr Arbeitsplätze, ne?
Das ist egal, ihre Häuser halten ja eh nicht so lange, weil ja dadurch dann auch Erdbeben ausgelöst werden und das dann sowieso alles zusammenfällt.
Ne, den schießt das Gas aus dem Wasserhahn, so alt das brennt ein bisschen im Auge, aber ansonsten ist es eigentlich relativ ungefährlich. Und äh also alle Klagen dagegen sind ja.
Fraking,
Top, da werden auch die Kinder, der ihrer Kinder noch was von haben und Clean Cole, das ist auch was, wo wovon die Kinder unserer Kinder was haben werden. Das ist im Prinzip du betreibst ein ähm Kohlekraftwerk und
machst dann so CO2-Speicher, führst die CO2 irgendwie ab und und ähm speicherst das zum Beispiel unter der Erde oder so. Auch eine Bombenidee, die machen wir mit ähm mit den Atom
Abfällen seit Jahren sehr erfolgreich.
Ja ja, der Asse, also das das läuft.
Hast du selten Probleme mit?
Und das ist, wer ist eigentlich auch unvorstellbar, dass äh dieses diese riesigen CO zwei Mengen dann irgendwann auf einmal schlagartig rausschießen und ähm irgendwie ein Ozonloch reißen oder so, das ist auch völlig ungefährlich. Das ist wirklich äh Ökopolitik.
Ähm äh,
Alafiness und das sollte man äh diese Arbeitsplätze sollte man auf jeden Fall erhalten, vor allem wenn es um so traditionsreiche ähm
und unlimitiert vorhandene Energiestoffe geht wie Kohle, die ja eine eine tausende bis Millionen Jahre Tradition hat, die Kohle, ne? Wenn du's überlegst, ne? Also finde ich sehr gut, dass er das macht. Dann ähm,
ähm möchte er gegen Visa Verletzungen vorgehen, die amerikanische Arbeiter in Nachteil versetzen, also mit anderen Worten,
Ausländer raus und dann möchte, dann hat der natürlich dieses ganze Drain the swarm, ist ja ein großes Thema, ne? Also diese ganze ganze Filz von Washington muss weg. Ähm,
möchte er, bewirbt er jetzt, dass er die Lobbyeinschränkungen wird er jetzt verhängen. Witzig ist, die gab's schon,
Ne, die hat Obama vorweisen sich vier oder acht Jahren sofort äh äh da angehängt, dass äh die waren aber bei unter Obama bei zwei Jahren. Er will auf fünf.
Also es bezieht sich auf Beamte im Staatsdienst, die diesen äh Quittieren dürfen dann nicht sofort in Lobby äh Institutionen wechseln, sondern eben erst nach zwei Jahren.
Ja, er möchte fünf. Und sie dürfen lebenslang nicht fürs Ausland arbeiten.
Also nicht für Unternehmen lobieren, die nicht amerikanisch sind, wobei das dann halt sehr schwierig wird mit aus China ausgekauften amerikanischen Unternehmen, von denen's auch so einige gibt.
Bei bei Obama war die Regel ähm zwei Jahre und auf jeden Fall nicht während des Termes des Präsidenten selber,
ne? Wäre ja auch eine Möglichkeit, geht dann äh dein dein Berater äh nach nach zwei Jahren oder nach vier Jahren wechselt der und ist dann Lobbyist, der hat äh vier Jahre lang nebenan gesessen, das geht natürlich so nicht. Aber da hat er im Prinzip eine eine sinnvolle Gesetzgebung von Obama jetzt nochmal ausgeweitet, um
um sagen zu können, dass er jetzt hier Sofortmaßnahme für Grain des ähm ergriffen hätte.
Also solange es halt nicht seine eigenen Unternehmen betrifft, ne? Weil es ja ganz ordentlich dabei sein eigenes Business äh weiter zu vermark.
Es ist ja was anderes, da gibt's ja keinen Interessenkonflikt. Also für ihn, ne? Hat er ja gesagt, hat er so gesagt.
Das ist für dich so absurd.
Also man kann sagen, der wartet so ein bisschen Nationalismus, äh Wirtschaftsprotektionismus angekündigt
und ähm angekündigt, dass er Dinge verbietet, die vorher schon verboten waren. Das kennen wir auch von äh aus anderen äh das kennen wir auch in Deutschland, ne? Das ist dann immer so getan wird. Äh äh also wer irgendwas noch nicht verboten,
bestünde jetzt eine Schutzlücke und jetzt müsste das verboten werden, ne? Haben wir von unserem Justizminister zum Beispiel häufig.
So verbunden.
Das Thema will ich gar nicht jetzt so angehen, da kann man da kann man sehr schöne Kolumnen von
Thomas Fischer, dem BGH Richter Thomas Fischer lesen, der besserer Jurist ist als ich, weil der hat das mal studiert und deswegen möchte ich das nur an diesem Punkt jetzt diese Parallele ziehen.
Ähm.
Dann äh was hat er noch gemacht? Also erstmal ähm hattest du dann diese Rechtsradikalen, die erstmal äh ähm Hitlergrüße gemacht haben und und Halle Trump gerufen haben.
Das war also Richard Spencers äh Chef eine so eines Nazi Thinktanks ähm National Policy Institut,
Nazi sag, ich bin eigentlich mit der Nazikeule vorsichtig, aber das in Amerika etablieren die sich gerade als die Alternative Rechte auch da wieder dieser Begriff Alternative, ne? Ähm,
das sind aber eigentlich also wirklich white Supremacis so, ne? Die also wirklich einer Rassenideologie folgen, von denen du dann so so Sachen hörst wie na ja alle bei jeder,
Bei jeder Rasse, die wir hier in USA haben, ist das völlig in Ordnung, dass die in ihren eigenen Interessen wählen. Äh bei den, bei den Schwarzen, bei den Latinos gehen wir vollkommen normal davon aus, dass die in ihren eigenen Interessen wählen. Aber bei uns stehen Weißen
äh mit unserer wichtigen kulturellen Identität. Äh wir dürfen das nicht, das finden wir nicht gut und hier ähm.
Mac America Greating. Ähm dann hat der Trump sich natürlich direkt wieder von denen distanziert, dann waren die sauer und dann hat er irgendwie wieder gesagt, der baut eine Mauer. Also das ist so diese Confusion Politics,
weshalb ich mich auch in der letzten Sendung eigentlich gewehrt habe, mich mit den mit dessen Inhalten irgendwie sinnvoll auseinanderzusetzen, weil die Zeit einfach noch nicht gekommen ist,
was er noch getan hat ist erstmal in Ruhe die Presse zusammenstauchen. Ist wirklich was Schönes passiert. Er hat gesagt.
Er lädt die Presse ein zu einem oft the Record Meeting im Trump Tower.
Ähm und dann sind die, dann kommen die ganze Presse, ne? Die die Lügenpresse, ne? Zieht sich dann ein Anzug an und kommt zum President Elect und üblicherweise äh ne äh gratuliert man dann, schüttelt sich die Hände und bereitet die äh
in in irgendeiner Form sage ich mal das gemeinsame Arbeiten vor, ja? Ähm,
Das heißt jetzt nicht, dass die sich über, dass die sagen, was sollen wir schreiben, aber die werden ja sehr viel Zeit miteinander verbringen und ähm.
Die werden da mitreisen, die sitzen dann immer in dieser, in dieser Pressekonferenz und so. Das ist nun mal so, dass es so etwas gibt. Ähm.
Jetzt kommen die zurück und sagen ey fucking fyring Squat.
Trump hätte also damit angefangen den Vorsitzenden von CFN äh CNN Jeff Zucker ähm anzuschreien. Ich hasse deinen Sender,
Alle bei bei CNN sind Lügner und du solltest dich was schämen. Andere Leute, die in diesem Treffen waren sagen, äh das das Treffen war ein totales Desaster, äh die die Vertreter der Fernsehsender ähm,
kamen rein und dachten, sie würden äh den Zugang,
diskutieren, den sie in der Trump-Administration haben, ja? Also mit wem können wir reden? Und äh stattdessen kriegen wir einfach nur ähm äh Trump-Style, Dressing Down, also einen Anschiss. Äh
andere bezeichnet's als total unangemessen und fucking unerhört. Und jetzt werde ich,
Das ist natürlich interessant, also das finde ich wirklich witzig, weil.
Also erstens zeigt das natürlich nicht von einer besonderen persönlichen Reife, aber das hatten wir ja schon mehrmals äh angesprochen, dass der zukünftige US-Präsident sich diese Blöße gibt, ähm die die Journalisten des Landes anzuschreien
Das ist einfach ähm das zeigt einfach
nicht von von Charakterstärke, ne? Das ist äh das sind Wesenszüge, die erwartet man einfach ab einem gewissen Reifegrad nicht mehr.
Fünfjährigen Verhalten.
Andererseits was, was erlaube,
Lügenpresse, ja? Äh dass sie sich alle da so äh einen Stelltich eingeben, dann noch ein NDA unterzeichnen,
Ja und sagen oft Record und so, oder? Ich weiß nicht, ob sie jetzt wirklich unterzeichnet haben oder ob sie einfach nur gesagt haben, ne, Gentleman Sagreament, wir reden nicht drüber,
Und sich dann zu wundern, dass der diesen schwanzwedelnden Pudel mal den Marsch bläst und ihm dann noch in dritter Phase den Gefallen zu tun.
Das dann zu erzählen und ihre Kränkung, ne? Das war aber gemein, er hat uns schlecht behandelt, ähm öffentlich zu machen, weil die Trump-Unterstützer sitzen natürlich da und sagen.
Super geil. Endlich hat unser Präsident mal diese diese Lügenpresse zur Sau gemacht und ähm,
ähm äh und und lachen sich ins Fäusschen, ne? Glengreenwhat sagt er zu sinngemäß. Ähm wer das nicht aushält, soll kein Journalist sein. Es ist überhaupt das Ziel, dass der das nur macht,
du bist der Fein, der Gegner des Präsidenten, deiner Aufgabe ist es, ihn stets äh kritisch äh zu beäugen. Also zwei,
denke ich, Blicke auf diese Sache, ne? Einerseits die Journalisten jetzt gekränkt sind und sagen, der ist nicht nett zu uns und damit natürlich überhaupt nicht ihrem eigenen äh Ruf guttun, ne.
Die wissen halt, sie hätten halt das hätten sie halt irgendwie anders, die die Rache hätten sie anders nehmen sollen als ihm diesen Ball zuzuspielen, das nämlich jetzt seine Fans sagen ha ha toll, ne?
Und selbst äh äh Glen Greenworld sagt, ja Trump hasst euch Big News, der größere Teil der Amerikaner ebenso. Jetzt jetzt macht mal was draus, ne? Ähm,
Dann noch eine sehr schöne Reaktion von Aboma, Cora Sani,
einer der top Kommander also der Top-Anführer des islamischen Staates in Afghanistan, der der Nachrichtenagentur Reuters in ihr Heft diskutierte,
Mach Isia. Becoss we can recruit thousands,
Das ist leider wahr, ne? Ähm was Unexpercted, that be americans will dick the onggraves, as day dit so. Anday dit so,
Ähm er weiß natürlich, äh dass Hass immer mit Hass begegnet wird und freut sich schon auf den Zulauf an Recruiten und auf die Zuspitzung äh der internationalen.
Äh Konflikte äh in die er mit seinen Kämpfertruppen mit seinem Heiligen Krieg da verwickelt ist.
Dazu sehr geiler Bericht auf Deonien, FBI an Covers Al-Qaeda, Plotto Just Sitback in Joy Collaps auf United State
zum Foto von so einem gelangweilten. Keiner kämpfer irgendwie auf dem Sofa. Die sich jetzt einfach nur noch hinlegen und dann einfach warten bis sie sich irgendwie alles selber in Luft auflegt. Und da ist was dran. Also das äh war ja nun auch wirklich eine.
Strategie, die Obama dann sogar gleich den Nobelpreis eingebracht hat, ungerechtfertigterweise, äh ja, aber,
Trotzdem richtiger Move, meiner Meinung nach, einfach diese Spannung zwischen äh den USA und den Islam zwischen Staaten, also nicht dem IS, sondern halt allen Ländern oder Islam eine Rolle spielt,
einfach abzubauen, ne? Seine Rede in Kairo und so weiter, äh ich meine, das hatte dann am Ende nicht unbedingt so viel.
Potential, viel Frieden zu erzeugen, wie wir dann auch gesehen haben,
aber ich glaube es hätte auch noch viel schlimmer sein können. Insbesondere was es in Wolfmindt von äh den USA betrifft, da,
wird jetzt im Prinzip zurückgedreht und jetzt haben wir irgendwie noch eine schlimmere Variante als das, was äh der andere Trottel George Bush da äh losgetreten hat seiner Zeit.
Ja, also wenn man sich jetzt so, ne, Meinungsforscher haben, klare Ergebnisse in in Doppelblindversuchen gegen wen würden sie am liebsten in den heiligen Krieg ziehen, ne?
Obama Busch, Trump, dann gibt's glaube ich eine klare Studie so und ähm darüber freut sich
der IS natürlich. Ähm, ich habe ja schon mehrfach gesagt, dass das äh Trump immer alles unser Gegenteil ankündigt und ich deswegen auf konkrete politische Zusagen.
Abwarte äh bis er was tut. Übrigens auch die Strategie der Bundesregierung, die ich aber hier an dieser Stelle nicht nicht begrüße, ja? Ähm.
Schauen wir mal an, wen er sich so als Mitarbeiter holt, ne. Ich habe ja schon gesagt, dieser sein Chefstratege wird dieser Bennon, ne? Ähm der,
Vier Jahre vorher dieses Hetzportal betrieben hat.
Das wird hierzu völlig völlig normal äh gefunden, ne? Man stelle sich mal vor, in Deutschland.
Ähm käme ein neuer äh Politiker äh ins äh in in Amt und Würden
Und würde sofort irgendwie, was weiß ich, Kai Dieckmann äh oder irgendwie diese kompakt oder irgendwelche komischen Hetzseiten, ähm äh deren Chef als seine Chefstrategen nehmen. Also das ist ja wirklich, dass er das, was mir.
Kai Dickmann, finde ich jetzt nicht so überraschend.
Der war ja schon mal Stritt, der war ja vorher äh,
Der hat der hat ja andersrum gewechselt, der war ja erst äh für Kohl, glaube ich, äh äh für Chorberater und ist dann dahingegangen. Ich meine, okay, dann spielen wir uns das gleiche mal mit ähm.
Wie heißt hier nochmal diese Brüderklicke da, äh die das Leistungsschutzrecht da quasi auf beiden Seiten weil Springer vorangebrach.
Nee, die gibt's so zwei B zwei Brüder, der eine ist irgendwie im Staat, der andere ist bei Springer.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja.
Wesentlichen vorangetrie.
Ähm.
Fällt mir gerade der Name nicht ein, also an der Stelle ist das schon so, ne? Aber wie du schon sagst, so kompakt und
hochgradig rechtspopulistisch geprägten Magazine in Deutschland das wäre sagen wir mal so in etwas Äquivalent zu Breitbart News.
So und was würden die schreiben? Das ist doch genau dieses Lügenpresse und Filz und so weiter, was die ganze Zeit kritisiert.
Ja, ich meine, wir haben das jetzt auch mit der AfD, die jetzt äh erstmal äh für den Bundesparteitag war das für den Bundesparteitag keine Presse eingeladen hat, ja und äh im Prinzip genau dieselben Strategiefern.
Äh aber ne, das, also nur mal, weil weil alle immer äh groß einen auf Lügenpresse und und Mainstream und Filz und was nicht alles
Das, meine lieben Freunde, ist genau das, was ihr bei was ihr, was ihr die ganze Zeit kritisiert und worüber ihr euch die ganze Zeit aufregt. Das ist genau das, was da gerade passiert
noch kurz ein paar Personalien, dann müssen wir auch mal langsam mit dem Ding durch sein. Ähm, Mike Pompio ähm wird der CIA General,
ähm bekannt äh für seinen Wunsch, Edward Snowden zu töten und alle Beschränkungen der Geheimdienste rückgängig zu machen.
Und bitte Guantanamo nicht aufzulösen, hatte Obama ja immer noch vorgehabt, aber acht Jahre lang nicht
nicht hingekriegt und außerdem würde er ganz gerne das Waterboarding wieder einführen, denn das hatte Obama zweitausendneun abgeschafft. Waterboarding, eine Foltermethode, bei der man Leute an die Nähe des Ertrinkens bringt oder an die Nähe des
Gefühls des Ertrinkens bringt unter ärztlicher Aufsicht. Also er will das Foltern wieder bringen, er möchte Mensch, er möchte.
Edward Stone, nur sonstige Whitzelblauer
er möchte die Beschränkungen der Geheimdienste rückgängig machen, da fragt man sich ernsthaft, welche das in den USA überhaupt noch sein sollten. Und er findet Gontanamo eine gute Idee, der wird also der CIA General, ne? CIA muss man dazu sagen. CA ist ja einer der Geheimdienste, der.
Ähm immer auch aktiv ähm diese Eingriffe macht, ne? Also diese ganzen CIA Coword Operations, der in irgendwelche Länder geht und dann da ein,
Umsturz herbeiführt oder so, ne. Ähm das ist die CIA, im Gegensatz zu NSA, die am Ende wenigstens immer noch nur äh Intelligence lieferte,
ähm die CIA sind also wirklich dann die, die manipulieren und sabotieren den.
Stehen, die stehen in deinem Schlafzimmer. Wenn's äh soweit ist, die LSE hat da nur eine Wanze.
Genau. Dann der ähm Turny General, also der äh Justizminister, ne oder nein, der.
Es ist er ist beides, er ist Justizminister und Staatsanwalt quasi in dieser Rolle.
Okay. Äh das ist
Cenetor Jeff Sessions, einer der ersten, die damals Trump and Dorst haben und der möchte natürlich der möchte
undokumentierten Einwanderern
den Weg zu einer permanenten Bürgerschaft verwehren. Das war einmal noch so ein Weg, da hatte Obama vor allem Möglichkeiten geschaffen, ne? Wenn er lang genug und so weiter, dann kommen äh dann wirst du irgendwann äh Permanent Residence bekommen
dann ist er ein sehr rumtönender Kritiker der Legalisierung von Marihuana,
Aber ähm hat ähm eine er hat unter Obama eine ähm,
Eine Initiative unterstützt, die die Strafen für äh Kokainbesitz äh niedriger machen. Was ich ganz schön finde, ne? Also.
Das ist ja eh so ein Trend, dass sozusagen die äh Drohungen, die von schwarzen äh den USA mehrheitlich genommen werden, höher bestraft sind als äh die weißen D.
Also guck groß, ein bisschen Koks, ne? Kannst noch mal machen. Hast ja auch einen langen Arbeitstag so als Politiker. Ähm.
Ist auch für Folter.
Der, dem käme dann übrigens laut Trump laut Trumps aktuellem Stand äh die Aufgabe zu äh Hidary Clinton zu verknacken oder nicht? Ähm.
Persönlich stattfinden.
Trump hat jetzt gesagt, wird nicht stattfinden, aber er wird es äh ihm überlassen. Also er, wenn er ihn fragt.
Oder vielleicht doch.
So dann ähm.
Gottes Schmerz.
National Security Advisor wird Michael Flinn. Das ist ein ehemaliger Loten General, der äh aus dem Kommando genommen wurde, wegen seines Führungsstils.
Seitdem labert der öffentlich von äh Islamisten und äh twittert solche Geschichten wie
vier of Muslims ist Rasional und hat irgendwie auch bei so Trump Kampagnen diese Lockhör-Abruhrrufe, ne? Also bring sie in den Knast, bring sie in den Knast rufe angefeuert. Das ist also der National Security Advisor,
äh auch da sehen wir, glaube ich, in welche Richtung ähm der Dampfer fährt. Da kann man jetzt schön beschwichtigen.
Ja, der war auch mit Putin irgendwie in einer schönen Gala von RT zu sehen und so letztes Jahr.
Dann hast du noch ähm äh also bei anderen gibt's noch Kandidaten, da sind zum Zeitpunkt dieser Sendung, die äh die äh.
Entscheidung noch nicht gefallen, da hast du so jemand wie,
Steven Mutchen, das ist so ein Ex äh Goldman Sachs äh Goldman Sexmitarbeiter, der jetzt als äh Kapitalverwalter, also Fondsmanager oder Hedgefond-Manager arbeitet
der Campaign Fundraiser war, also der hat die Kohle reingeschafft für den ähm für den Trump und soll jetzt das Department of Trasural bekomm.
Wer sich so ein bisschen mit die Bankstar und Finanzkollaps und wo bleiben eigentlich das Volk und es muss was sich was ändern und wir werden alle verarscht,
auseinandergesetzt hat, ne? Dem sagt Goldman Sex was, ja? Und dem sagt auch das Wort Hedgefund, et,
So, da habt ihr jetzt, das habt ihr jetzt davon, dass ihr, äh, dass ihr euch, ähm, dass ihr euch habt, beschwichtigen lassen und dass ihr dachtet, so schlimm wird das sicherlich nicht werden, wollen wir erstmal schauen, was passiert. Der Wirtschaftsprotektionismus wird bestimmt
ganz tolle Sache werden und sowas wie äh wie irgendwelche Kapitalisten, die uns regieren, das wollen wir auf gar keinen Fall,
denn das das geht ja nun mal überhaupt nicht, bitteschön. Da können wir Ex-Goldman Sex äh einfach mal als Department of Tragery haben und dann haben wir noch äh so einen schönen, der ist mir auch aufgefallen, der Ölmiadia Harold Hamm
Harold Ham, ähm der soll der Energiestrategische Berater werden, sondern er weiß natürlich auch,
was der. So, da kannst du sehen, da wird jetzt aber mal so richtig der Filz aufgelöst, so, Junge, Junge. Da geht's jetzt richtig äh geht's jetzt richtig zur Sache. So.
Dass das System komplett aus der Spur.
Da wir ja genau, da wird da wird das System aber richtig drunter leiden. Da könnt ihr mal sehen, was ihr euch jetzt gewählt habt ähm und was euch jetzt die äh was ihr euch jetzt noch irgendwie so äh schönreden könnt.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch ähm auch.
Nur bei der war, war auch schon bei Middromny im im Team. Also.
Ja, weil also es ist halt äh wirklich ähm wir haben sehr selbst unter unter Systemkritikern und Querdenkern äh klar sein, dass diese Personalauswahl da jetzt ähm,
nicht wirklich äh Change Weekend belief in verspricht, wenn ich diesen dreckigen Witz mal machen darf.
Ja, also aber ich meine vielleicht ist das ja auch alles nur Propaganda und Chemtrails und.
Ja, ist eigentlich eine eine geniale Strategie. Ja, ist echt geniale Strategie.
Nächstes Thema wenden wir uns äh eigentlich, wir haben überlegt, ob wir dieses Thema bei uns drin haben, also diese Trump-Sache werden wir auch jetzt äh in Zukunft nicht weiter behandeln. Das ist nicht Netzpolitik.
Diese Tramsache. Na ja, die wird uns, glaube ich, die nächsten vier Jahre noch begleiten. Ähm es ist nicht noch nicht Netzpolitik, aber es wird auch Netzpolitik,
äh äh sein, äh nicht nur, was die Überwachungsfrage betrifft, sondern sicherlich auch, was so die äh Regulierung, äh Netzneutralität und Ähnliche äh Dinge betrifft, da kann man jetzt eigentlich ganz froh sein, dass das zumindest vorerst äh in der Obama-Zeit noch so halbwegs in die trockene Tücher äh gebracht
worden ist, kann man sich ganz gut ausmalen, wie das unter Trump ausgesehen hätte in den letzten zwei Jahren.
Und äh da erwarte ich auch äh nicht nicht viel viel Gutes. Man ist einzige äh was man hoffen.
Also hoffen, dass wir die äh sehr, also ich wünsche ganz ehrlich, ich wünsche der USA äh.
Dass sie sich fangen können.
Ja, vor allem, dass sie sich wieder.
Die waren stellenweise auch auf einem guten Weg,
Das ist natürlich jetzt alles unter höchster Gefahr und natürlich betrifft es auch uns. Also mindestens mittelbar.
Deswegen ist das alles kein kein guter Move. In gewisser Hinsicht ist es aber auch mit solchen Extremen. Ich meine, das kann halt jetzt auch ein oder hat auch schon einen Schock,
bewirkt, weil es ja jetzt auch nicht so, dass es überhaupt niemand gibt, der so halbwegs liberal denkt und die,
Küstenbewohner der USA, also New York, auf der einen Seite das Angeles San Francisco, Valley, Kalifornien, et cetera. Die sind ja schon ganz anders aufgestellt. Und da wird man jetzt sehen,
ich denke, dass der ist, dass dieser Riss, den die USA schon seit zehn Jahren haben, spätestens äh ausgelöst natürlich auch durch diese ganze.
Die Terrornummer,
also länger als vor zehn Jahre, zwanzig Jahre würde ich sagen, geht das seit seit Bild Clinton eigentlich so äh auf's aufs aufs Feld getreten ist, ist diese Polarisierung so extrem geworden. Ähm Tea Partybewegung und so weiter,
Man hat jetzt so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass jetzt wird der Bogen langsam so weit überspannt. Bisher waren das immer nur so Drogen und Andeutungen und jetzt jetzt wird's halt richtig.
Eklig so und das das kann in jede Richtung ausschlagen, es wird sehr viele negative Folgen haben, da können wir uns schon mal drauf einstellen.
Aber es kann natürlich auch ein Backlash geben und da muss man natürlich jetzt auch zusehen, dass vielleicht nicht gleich äh alle äh politischen Flüchtlinge im Prenzlauer Berg werden, sondern dass vielleicht auch noch ein paar vor Ort bleiben und äh dagegen halten.
Diese Polarisierung, da hast du ähm was was Wichtiges gesagt, das was wir ja eigentlich in der Gesellschaft äh sehen,
ist, dass Menschengruppen immer und immer mehr wieder gegeneinander kämpfen, gegeneinander aufgebracht sind, ähm.
Gegeneinander aufgebracht werden.
Gegeneinander aufgebracht werden, einander hassen und da gibt's, glaube ich, einen, der
Also wirklich so einen der wichtigsten Texte, die ich in letzter Zeit gelesen habe für die Zeiten, die vor uns äh sind. Äh ist von äh Christian Stöcker,
Christian Stöcker war lange Jahre der Ressortleiter von Spiegel Online Netzfeld, hat auch ein Buch geschrieben, Nerd Attack
und ist, glaube ich, kürzlich hat er eine Professur angetreten für Journalismus in Hamburg und der schreibt seit einigen Monaten jetzt regelmäßig noch eine Kolumne auf Spiegel online. Und diese Kolumne heißt die Ratte in uns und ähm da sagte, es wird viel darüber gesprochen, warum Herr Rap
blicken und Hass auf andere derzeit so populär sind. Und erklärt ähm im Prinzip darin darin die Mechanismen.
Der sozialen Abwertung. Warum? Soziale Abwertung anderer auf uns belohnend ist. Und auch warum
Identitätsstiftung ebenso eine Identitäts unsere deutsche Identität oder unsere Identität als weiße gegenüber den anderen äh belohnend ist und er,
Geht da legt das weit aus um quasi süchtig macht, ne? Das das macht süchtig, weil es uns belohnt, weil wir uns dadurch besser fühlen und was uns, was uns besser fühlen macht, macht uns auch süchtig. Also er hat da so simple,
psychologische Prinzipien, um diese diese äh soziale Abwertung und den Hass zu erklären und er schließt diese Kolonne mit dem Satz
Die wichtigste Schlussfolgerung aus dieser Erkenntnis ist diese. Das derzeit so häufig eingabel eingeforderte Verständnis für diejenigen, die Rassismus, Sexismus
Homophobie und so weiter als Krücken fürs eigene Selbstwertgefühl benutzen ist fehlgeleitet,
Alkoholiker hilft man ja auch nicht, indem man Verständnis für seine Sucht zeigt,
man hilft ihm, indem man ihn dabei unterstützt vom Alkohol loszukommen. Und zu diesem Zweck im Idealfall sein Leben so umzubauen, dass er auf anderem Wege findet, dass er andere Wege findet, sich wohl zu fühlen. Und
Das ist wirklich der spricht mir wirklich aus der Seele. Und wenn ich da jetzt ganz kurz einbringen darf, äh.
Ausnahmsweise.
Den Text hätte ich gerne genommen äh als Mottoankündigung äh für das Motto des
dreiunddreißig C drei, Workshop, wo wir genau auch auf diese dieses Gegeneinander aufbringen der Menschen Bezug nehmen und uns darauf konzentrieren wollen, ein Workshop herbeizuführ.
In dem Zusammenhang nach Deutschland. Weiß nicht, ob das so eine,
Was ja schon angedeutet, ob das jetzt sozusagen für uns überhaupt ein Thema ist, aber ich glaube, in diesen Zeiten ist gerade alles irgendwie für uns auch ein Thema, weil äh die Dinge hängen einfach nur mal zusammen,
hat ja auch irgendwann mal äh auf die Frage, was ist Netzpolitik gesagt? Naja, Netzpolitik ist, äh ist das, was wir später mal Politik nennen werden.
Ja, das äh fand ich eigentlich sehr schön, weil ist ja auch so, ich meine, diese diese wir orientieren uns jetzt zwar in gewisser Hinsicht an,
an an unseren an den digitalen Dingen in die wir mehr Einblick zu haben glauben und und sagen wir auch unsere kulturelle Prägung durch das Netz. Aber am Ende ähm.
Wir hat auch der der Club, den wir uns ja auch beide zugehörig fühlen, schon auch immer.
Politik gemacht, ja, schon oder zumindest politisch argumentiert oder politisch gesellschaftspolitisch, mindestens gesellschaftspolitisch äh Stellung bezogen.
Ich habe aber wohl meinen. Der Lehnstuhl Computerclub ist ein anderer.
Genau, das Thema, was wir jetzt noch nachschieben wollten, ist Angela Merkel entschließt sich äh.
Nochmal anzutreten. Sie will äh wohl ihrem alten Ziehvater Helmut Kohl den Rekord äh abjagen als Dauerkanzler.
Und ja, hat sie angekündigt, dass sie jetzt nochmal antritt. Ich fand's nicht wirklich überraschend. Auf der einen Seite, also ich wäre eher sehr überrascht und äh gewisser Hinsicht ist auch enttäuscht gewesen, ehrlich gesagt, wenn sie es nicht äh gemacht hätte.
Und ja, weiß ich nicht. Ist das überhaupt eine Nachricht für uns?
Na insofern, als das äh Angela Merkel jetzt, also da hätte man auch nicht,
Also sie wird jetzt quasi als die letzte, das letzte Bollwerk gegen den Faschismus äh äh gesehen, ne. Und äh Jeff Javis äh feiert sie ja jetzt auch irgendwie, ne? Der soll's eigentlich immer nur nix anderes zu tun hatte, als die Deutschen dafür zu kritisieren, dass sie Datenschutz haben,
und damit seinem Google im Weg stehen, er hat dann wahrscheinlich ein paar Aktien oder so. Ähm und äh.
Jetzt feiert er uns für unsere Privatsphären und.
Für Privatsphäre und nein nicht unbedingt, aber vor allem für die für die besonder besonnene Politik. Ich glaube, der hat sich zu lange mit mit Datenschutzkritik auseinandergesetzt, um zu sehen, was in Deutschland auch gerade los ist, aber äh,
Deadlef the sight, das Problem, was ich heute sehe, ist, dass Angela Merkel antritt, ohne klar zu erklären,
Mit welchem Ziel sie noch antritt. Und ähm.
Zu welchem politischen Programm.
Ja warum willst du warum? So, ich meine das ist das erste was du äh einen Bewerber fragst, ne, beim Job. So, hallo, ja was beworben, ne? Ja, beworben. Warum?
Ja, das reicht dann eben in der Regel nicht, ne?
Na das würde ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Ich bin mal gespannt, wie wie das rezipiert wird. Sie kann sich nur auf einen ganz anderen Wahlkampf äh äh gefasst machen, nachdem was wir Eingangs äh dann doch.
Und ich denke, das ist ihr sehr wohl bewusst, dass das jetzt äh like no over ist. Also das, das hat mit allen äh Wahlkämpfen, die sie bisher hat führen müssen, nichts zu tun.
Also da da kommt sie äh noch nicht mal aus der Position der Stärke heraus, noch nicht mal was äh ihre eigene Partei betrifft und schon gar nicht was eben diese drohende äh
AfD Nummer da hier unser deutsches Breitbadprogramm.
Die werden die gleiche Strategie fahren. Aber sie weiter. Fahren sie ja seit Jahr.
Ich meine es ist nicht so, dass sie das nicht weiß, sondern sehenden Auges, sagt sie halt so, mir noch egal äh stelle mich jetzt hier hin, ich kann nicht anders, ich äh.
Ich mache das jetzt so und ähm.
Ich stehe jetzt sagen wir mal dem politischen Gesamtmenge Lage äh der CDU nicht unbedingt sehr nah, ja.
Aber man beginnt ja schon auf das gesamte äh politische System schon äh siminär zu schauen im Sinne von was geht an sich noch,
Und was geht gar nicht? Und dieses das was geht gar nicht rauszuhalten ist für mich.
Viel wichtiger als äh mir jetzt zu viele Gedanken über äh die konkreten Nancen äh einer einer politischen Ausgestaltung zu machen. Zumal man ja auch gerade bei Angela Merkel gesehen hat.
Dass dass auch die CDU diese konservative Seite in Deutschland.
Sich nicht aktuellen Bewegungen und aktuellen Entwicklungen, langfristigen Entwicklungen vor allem auch äh vollständig entziehen kann.
Ich meine, ihr Piwot im Bereich Atom ist,
beeindruckend, ja? Also erst sozusagen noch im Main Mainstream der eigenen Partei äh mitschwimmend dieses ach, so schlimm ist das doch gar nicht und jetzt verlängern wir hier nochmal die Laufzeit der Atomkraftwerke, was kann schon passieren
passiert was und dann einfach auch äh so die Kraft zu haben, zu sagen, okay, ich ich sehe das jetzt anders als vorher,
Das ist schon, das ist schon so ein bisschen auch ein äh,
Markenzeichen einerseits von ihr, aber ich würde würde das sogar im Prinzip der kompletten CDU zugestehen, mit Ausnahmen natürlich bei einzelnen Leuten, dass dass sie sozusagen.
Im im Kontext dieser Gesellschaft noch stehen.
Tim, was bist du denn für ein Alternativmedium? Wir müssen jetzt hier eindreschen. Nächstes Thema.
Ja, aber ich meine, das, das ist so der der Aspekt, der der mir da so primär äh äh kommt und äh,
Ich hoffe trotzdem, dass dass wir dass wir da einen lusteren ähm Schlagabtausch haben werden, was was tatsächliche Ideen betrifft, ne. Aber,
es geht einfach nicht anders, dass wir äh Kräfte stärken, die die einfach nur nur alles kaputt hauen wollen.
So ist es. Inhalte, mehr Inhalte. Ähm so jetzt endlich Netzpolitik, meine Güte, ich bin so froh, dass wir diesen ähm.
Wir hatten ja kürzlich er.
Die Klage der Opposition im NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss, die gescheitert ist. Jetzt haben wir eine, mit der die.
Opposition durchgekommen ist und zwar haben sie vor dem äh Bundesgerichtshof sich beklagt, weil ja die große Koalition sich gegen eine Einladung Edward Snowdens nach Deutschland sperrt,
Ähm der die Opposition im NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss wollte, würde gerne den einzigen,
wirklichen Kronzeugen zu dieser ganzen Thematik anhören und die Koalition
sagt, nee, auch Quatsch jetzt
Können wir auch ohne machen, ne? Da muss man jetzt nicht direkt den Edward Storn hier holen. Klar natürlich die die über die Überlegung dabei ist, dass sie äh Schiss haben, sich mit den Amerikanern anzulegen. Wenn sie sich jetzt den Snowden in in so ein Parlament äh
Hering einladen,
zumal ja dann noch das Risiko im Raum eine Stunde, dass der Norden, wenn er einmal Fuß auf deutschen Boden hat hier sich der Asylantenflut anschließen könnte, ne?
Oh Gott, da wird's ja noch schlimmer. Noch einer.
Noch einer, eine Boot ist voll. Nein, so. Und,
Deswegen natürlich ganz klar will die Koalition und die Bundesregierung das verhindern. Jetzt haben die äh Ermittlungsrichter des Bundesgerichtshofs dem,
diesem Antrag am elften November zweitausendsechzehn stattgegeben, das heißt, dass die, dass der NSL-Untersuchungsausschuss.
Eine Einladung Snowdens ähm herbeiführen muss,
Ähm,
aber das, das kann der gar nicht selber, sondern der der NSR-Untersuchungsausschuss muss ein entsprechendes Ersuchen an die Bundesregierung stellen. Das heißt, ihr könnt den roten Teppich wieder einrollen, die Bundesregierung wird dann wortreich
den Reifenbrand austreten wieder, ne? Snowden wird,
großer Wahrscheinlichkeit nicht kommen, aber es ist wenigstens mal der Punkt, dass nicht die äh Großkoalitionäre,
Den Untersuchungsausschuss blockieren können, der sich ja letztlich gegen ihre eigene Regierung äh gegen ihre eigene Regierung richtet. Also der NSR-Untersuchungsausschuss wird jetzt dieses Anliegen,
Das entsprechende Ersuchen an die Bundesregierung stellen und die wird es dann eben.
Wortreich äh begründen, warum dieses Amtshilfeersuchen äh zurückgewiesen wird oder dem nicht entsprochen wird.
Aber das muss den Schuh musste sich dann sozusagen anziehen.
Den muss sie sich anziehen. Ähm ein, ja, ein kleiner Erfolg äh wir werden,
Ich halte das für unwahrscheinlich, dass die Bundesregierung sagt, ach ja, endlich fragt ihr mal, äh wir haben hier eh schon so ein, wir haben ja eh schon hier ein Ticket oder so
werden das auch die der das ganze Handeln der Bundesregierung insbesondere der BND-Gesetzgebung deutet ja nicht darauf hin,
sie darauf jetzt großartig Bock hätten, aber.
Wenigstens werden SPD und CDU mit nach ihrer jahrelangen Blockage äh äh Blockierstrategie durch dieses Urteil des BG BGH ähm doch durchaus vorgeführt und das zurecht.
Und hat natürlich auch äh Präzedenzcharakter für zukünftige Arbeit äh zukünftiger ähm Ausschüsse.
Das halt sozusagen so ein Ersuchen, so dass dann eben auch in andere Richtungen äh äh geht und äh verhindert wird oder versucht wird, zu verhindern von vornherein auch schon mal ganz was aufgestellt ist,
immer gut.
Dann äh haben wir in den letzten Wochen ja glaube ich über diese ähm größeren Detox-Attacken geredet, die da äh den DNS-Anbieter dünn getroffen haben
und zu einem Ausfall des nordamerikanischen Internets äh geführt haben. Äh Julian Assange war überzeugt, dass es wie so vieles natürlich nur mit ihm zu tun hatte und äh jetzt.
Jetzt gibt es eine und eine ein.
Den Verdacht, äh dass diese Dine of Serviceattacke möglicherweise von einem frustrierten Playstationsspieler ausgeführt wurde. Ähm der irgendwie mit,
Playstation, Service nicht zufrieden war und dann seine Dine offs sich ein Bordnetz aus rund einhundertfünfzigtausend internetfähigen Geräten, also,
Glühbirnen, Haushaltsgeräte, Lampen, Kameras, hast du nicht gesehen, Gemiete.
Kühlschränke.
Kühlschrank, Toaster, was nicht alles.
Ja? Das glaube ich ist kein Geheimnis, dass man sich so etwas mieten kann, dass Bottennetze auch zu diesem Zwecke erstellt werden, um sie zu vermieten.
Und dann hatte er eben sein Bodnetz äh nicht
so gute Anweisungen gegeben, die dazu geführt hätten, dass sie das PlayStation-Network lahmlegen, sondern äh die gesamten dünnen äh Server lahmlegen und damit äh hatte er zu Störungen bei Twitter Spotify, Notflix eBay und anderen Diensten,
geführt. Wie gesagt, möglicherweise das Ganze wird noch untersucht.
Aber ähm das wäre es wirklich ähm also das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie,
Auch wenn es von seiner Auswirkung her ein ein Terrorakt ist, ja, also geeignet äh Angst und Schrecken in der Bevölkerung herbeizuführen, durch einen größeren Ausfall von Infrastruktur. Äh das ist seit so wir,
Terror definiert, das habe ich jetzt wenig ausgedacht, ne? Ähm.
Aber es ist halt schon irgendwie amüsant, dass wir in in so interessanten Zeiten leben, wo dann mehr oder weniger an der Playsie sitzen, sagt oh.
Dich mache ich platt.
Bitcoins kaufen, den das jetzt man.
Mann. Ja, Rage. So. Das ist die.
Dann haue ich das eben alles kaputt. Nee, aber es sieht eben danach aus.
Ja, der durchdrehende Heimrauter ist so die brennende Mülltonne des Internets.
Ähm.
Burn, Baby, Burn.
Natürlich ist es aber auch ein äh.
Kameras waren das uns bei dieser Attacke. Webkims. Na ja.
Meines Kameras wie dem auch sei. Ähm Probleme ist, dass es natürlich nicht sein darf
dass äh dass es dass Infrastruktur so einfach angegriffen werden kann, ne? Wer diese Internet-Offings, die weiß, das sind dann Probleme wegen der fehlenden Update-Fähigkeit oder der nicht nicht vernünftigen Update-Fähigkeit ähm,
aber bei der bei der äh ITF wird das natürlich auch.
Heiß diskutiert, weil die inzwischen sich sagen na ja lange können wir das.
Können wir das nicht mehr ohne technische Gegenmittel äh äh oder lange können wir diesen Zustand nicht,
Dulden, weil sonst werden sich die Regulierer ähm einmischen. Also zum Beispiel die ähm FCC, die also sagt,
Pass auf. Ähm,
Wir gucken uns das jetzt nicht mehr lange an, sondern jetzt begreifen wir da regulierend ein und du möchtest natürlich eher, dass du äh technische Maßnahmen auf Netzwerkebene hast
um die Nile of Serviceangriffe ordentlich wegzufiltern statt einer
direkten Regulierung des Staates. Insofern die Arbeiten, die Engineers arbeiten mit Hochdruck an verschiedenen Möglichkeiten Gegenmaßnahmen gegen solche ähm gegen solche Dinal of Serviceangriffe auf Netzwerkebene,
zu ergreifen.
Äh da sind wir auch an einem Rande von eben ja, Traffic-Überwachen, Traffic Filter, äh Netzneutralitätsverletzungen äh werden da immer wieder.
Angenommen oder beziehungsweise solche Maßnahmen werden immer als Beispiele gegen ähm.
Netzneutralität angeführt, also das muss man ein bisschen unter
im Auge behalten, wie das da am Ende passiert. Dann ist es wahrscheinlich besser, äh wenn es, wenn es von Ingenieuren auf technischer Ebene sorgfältig gemacht wird, als das jetzt irgendwie äh wegen so ein paar äh Kameras am Internet,
Lange Regulation Regularien geschrieben werden.
Wäre durch, ja.
Generell ist nicht bisschen hätte das immer an meinen äh den ich meinen ersten, aber ich habe, ich habe mal einen Vortrag auf Kongress gehalten, der so vierundneunzig irgendwie war,
wo habe ich das schon mal erwähnt, wie ich so mit Hans Hübner irgendwie dem,
aufkommenden Stolz der Hakra Szene, dass das Internet ja jetzt sozusagen auserwählt ist als die Zukunft,
Das war so Zeit so, oh, jetzt das Web und jetzt alle Internet so, ja. Nicht mehr Computer surft, nicht mehr Microsoft Networker, Internet, Internet alle waren so total hyperintegriert. Und dann haben wir so einen Vortrag gehalten, der als ich eher so als Satire gedacht war, hieß irgendwie, warum Internet scheiße ist,
einfach mal so.
Einfach mal so ein bisschen mit dem Finger drauf gezeigt und so. Leute, wisst ihr überhaupt, welchen Zustand sich das irgendwie befindet? Und da wollt ihr jetzt irgendwie die die Infrastruktur dieses Planetens drauf äh loslassen? Natürlich noch alle,
bin mir nicht so sicher, ob irgendeine Security bei uns damals schon eine große Rolle gespielt hat, aber ich denke immer wieder, schmunzelnd äh zurück. Das ist.
Finde.
Teilweise wirklich, das ist leider damals nicht aufgezeichnet worden. Vierundneunzig, da gab's noch keine.
Online.
Das ging erst so neunundneunzig los.
Oh, schade.
Ja, sehr schade. Äh ich habe auch keinen keins kein Skript mehr äh glaube ich äh nicht, aber äh,
Auf jeden Fall haben sich alle schön aufgeregt und und kamen dann halt auch gleich mit interessanten Lösungen und so. Ja, wieso? Webserver und so. Es gi,
und so weiter. Also es wurde sozusagen auch aus dieser informierten Szene gleich von Anfang an mit äh mit Bandaid äh geantwortet und ist doch ist doch egal, wenn es nicht richtig funktioniert. Wir haben noch irgendwie Heißkleber und äh Graffatapep und und Kabelbinder,
Da kriegt man das doch schon irgendwie hin, ne? Und jetzt insofern ist das jetzt sehr schön, zu sehen, finde ich, dass äh da ITF jetzt über solche Sachen auch nachgedacht wird, weil
denke schon, es ist natürlich immer ein offener Wettlauf, aber es ist halt zuletzt.
Zu optimistisch rangegangen worden. Erst ist Security an sich so optimistisch äh behandelt worden, sie die ganze Debatte um letztendrübt, hatte die PS und so weiter, was einfach ewig gedauert hat, bis sich irgendwie äh was getan hat. Auch der,
Fortschritt in Richtung IPV sechs hat viel zu lange gedauert. Und jetzt,
müssen eben auch solche Sachen, solche Detox-Sachen äh einfach mit eingebaut werden, in die Protokolle. Es ist richtig, meiner Meinung nach,
Das Grundgeräusch dieses Netzes nachhaltig zu verändern, um einfach auch mehr Resistenzen äh zu schaffen, weil das sind natürlich auch alles äh,
extrem im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes destabilisierende äh Momente, die.
Einfach nicht überhand nehmen dürfen. So, also man wird immer hinterherlaufen ein wenig, aber es ist gut, die den Abstand zumindest zu verringern.
Ein bisschen den Abstand verringern können. Leute, die das Browser Plug-in Progstube installiert haben.
Ähm das ist nämlich jetzt Dirk von Gelen aufgefallen,
Als äh das Plug-in, was ihn äh verraten hat und seine Daten in diese ähm in diesen Datensatz gelegt hat, der äh unter dem,
Unter der Überschrift nackt im Netz eben von von NDR untersucht wurde. Ähm insofern bitte,
deinstalliert das Browser Plugin Progstube es verrät. Alle eure äh URLs, die ihr besucht äh woanders hin und dann werden landen die bei sogenannten was weiß ich.
Genauso wie jetzt äh letzte Sendung schon dieses Verpuff Tra.
Genau wie dieses T.
Überhaupt sind halt so Plugins auch wirklich ein zweischneidiges Schwert.
Wir haben übrigens zu diesen äh auf welche jetzt schon Congressvorträge empfehlen. Er kann ja jetzt den nicht anders machen, Mist. Äh also zu diesem nackt im Ne,
auch eine Analyse äh beim beim beim Congress geben. Äh also installieren wir denn.
Dann haben wir eine, es ist endlich das eingetreten, was ich mir immer gewünscht habe. Ich also als.
Als das Internet noch Scheiße war, ja
ähm gab es relativ wenige Top-Level Domains. Toplevel Domains sind die äh ist also das Punkt com? Punkt DE Punkt.
Netz Punkt org.
Punkte hast du nicht gesehen, ja? Und wie viele von euch sicherlich schon mitbekommen haben, gibt es, gab es jetzt irgendwie so ein Dammbruch, dass er jetzt inzwischen jeden Scheiß als Top-Level um äh registrieren kann.
Punkt, was war, was war nochmal das längste äh all Finanzberater oder irgendwie sowas? Also kannst.
Weiß ich nicht. Ich habe irgendwo einen Twitter-Account äh abonniert, der mir am laufenden Meter so top Level Domain Änderungen äh raushaut und das ist äh ja ganz lustig, was da alles.
So und ich habe dann irgendwie als ich als das losging vom zwei Jahren oder drei Jahren war das dann habe ich irgendwie so überlegt, welche Top-Limit du mainst würde ich denn kaufen, ja? Wenn ich jetzt irgendwie hundert noch was
tausend Dollar überhätte. Und ich weiß ganz genau, welche ich gekauft hätte. Ähm und zwar in dieser Reihenfolge. Ähm Punkt zweihundertfünfundfünfzig.
Punkt eins Punkt local und Punkt Box, weil.
Eine Fritzbox sich ein relativ verbreiteter ähm Router.
Und die hält sich nicht an diese Konvention, die meisten geben dir perford, nennen sie das lokale Subnetz Punkt local und alles ist gut. Ähm und der Aufruf des Routers geschieht dann eben unter was weiß ich, Routerpunkt lauken oder so
ne. Ähm die Fritzbox nennt aber äh
möchte aber gerne, dass das Atmen unter Face unter Fritz Punkt Box aufgerufen werden kann und benutzt deswegen die lokale äh Domain Punkt Box.
Ärgerlicherweise äh hat gibt es seit dem elften elften noch ein treffendes Datum. Die Toplevel Domain Punkt Box.
Jetzt nehme ich Karneval im Netz.
So und jetzt können viele Fritzboxnutzer im internen Netz nun ähm nix mehr aufrufen.
Ähm weil einige der äh weil die die Domain, die den Server eben dieses Punkt Box reserven müssen und AVM mit seinen Fritzboxen ist äh ein bisschen blöd dran.
Haben die sich Fritz Punkt Box denn jetzt gesichert? Also.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, warte mal, ist.
Also äh ja, musst du, musst du von draußen machen, weil hier steht auch eine.
Äh ich muss mal äh ach so ja Mist, ich kann.
Genau das.
Okay, warte, ich muss das von, ja, ich verstehe. Ähm Moment, Moment, Moment, also ansonsten werden sie jetzt live Zeuge, wie wir uns eine Domain graben.
Sagen, Server in vier verschiedenen Ländern. Müssen wir nochmal in Ruhe anschauen, aber ähm daran sie
man ähm wie blöd das ist, wenn man wenn man von bestimmten Konventionen ab äh weicht, ne. Es gab auch eine andere.
Einen anderen Routerhersteller. Das ist jetzt so ein dreiviertel Jahr her. Die hatten sich irgendwie eine eine Domain genommen, die es draußen und drinnen gibt,
und oder die,
Und dann gab, haben sie irgendwann diese Domain gekündigt, dann hat die sich jemand anders gegrappt, ja? Und dann hattest du auf einmal irgendwie ein paar hunderttausend Nutzer dieses dieses Routers, die den konfigurieren wollten und dann bei auf deiner Span-Seite gelandet sind, wo du sie mit Werbung äh zugeballert hast, auch ganz
ganz amüsant, aber das wollte ich eigentlich nur so ein bisschen als.
Als kleinen äh rausschmeißer äh Scherz hier mit reinbringen, äh dass äh Trolle werden, Trollen und das wird sicherlich noch sehr amüsant werden, wenn ich dann irgendwann mal die Punkt zweihundertfünfundfünfzig habe oder so.
Also bei Punkt Box kann man bisher nur vorregistrieren irgendwie Fritz Punkt Box äh wird mir als äh markiert.
Kaufe kaufe.
Wobei das heißt jetzt gar nichts, weil ich weiß nicht ganz genau, worüber das jetzt hier läuft irgendwie, das erzählt mir wahrscheinlich hier äh jeder, weil sozusagen alle alle noch frei sind.
Aber äh steht hier jetzt erstmal so. Ist äh Wählbö.
Ja kaufen. So.
Als kleiner Scherz. Kommen wir nochmal zum.
Liebes AVM, bitte. Das müsst ihr fixen, also äh das Ding ist jetzt durch, ja? Ihr könnt äh,
dem Neuen Onar von Fritz Punkt Box. Egal ob ich es bin oder Linus nicht vorenthalten, dass äh die Webseite dazu aufgerufen wird, weil wo kommen wir denn da hin, ja?
Und es gibt eine einfache Lösung, das heißt Punkt local, das funktioniert irgendwie seit Jahren. Äh Facett, kauft euch mal Max, dann wisst ihr auch, wie das funktioniert und das Problem hättet ihr schon immer äh problemlos lösen können
Und wenn man zwei von einem scheiß Teilen irgendwie äh äh im Haus hat, dann funktioniert das ohnehin nicht. Also geht real. Man.
Mann, ey.
Also Gothi, die mein Fritz Punkt Box wäre nicht verfügbar.
Okay.
Na ja, habt ihr nochmal Glück gehab.
Oder Pech?
Mit uns seid ihr noch klargekommen, ja.
Wir hätten uns da über eine ja. Ich meine, wir erwerben's da auf jeden Fall finanziell. Eigentlich.
Unser Transition-Team hätte sich mit euch in Verbindung gesetzt und da wäre noch was drin.
Time. Das werde ich jetzt immer sagen.
Lügenfritzbox. Ähm so, kommen wir zum letzten Thema. Also, die letzte Vorverkaufsphase des äh dreiunddreißig C drei beginnt,
Freitag, den fünfundzwanzigsten November um zehn Uhr deutsche Zeit. Und ähm.
Wollte eigentlich nur kurz ein paar Worte zu diesem Vorverkauf loswerden, weil äh Leute sind natürlich verzweifelt sind und sich dann auch und ihrer Wut Luft machen und das dann auf äh auf.
Irgendwem kanalisieren im besten Fall im schlimmsten Fall auf mich oder auf das äh Presal-Team, das diesen Vorverkauf mache. Ähm.
Niemand von uns sitzt da und freut sich, dass irgendwer kein Ticket bekommen hat. Niemand. Ähm.
Es ist aber nun mal eine Tatsache, dass es eine zu große oder dass wir einen Mitdienst ungefähr zwölftausend Tickets, die wir verkaufen können.
Nicht der Nachfrage gerecht werden. Können.
Und wir wissen auch, wie schmerzhaft das für jede einzelne Person ist, die kein Ticket bekommt,
Und niemand von uns fühlt sich damit wohl, dass das passiert. Und wir,
ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen, wie viele Schicksale, ja
regelmäßig bei uns aufschlagen. Das war beim Camp schon so der Fall und das haben wir jetzt in diesem Jahr und das haben wir auch letztes Jahr beim Kongress in der Form gehabt. Mit Tränen in den Augen wird dann irgendwann
ist der Sack zu? Da ist die Grenze erreicht, wo die die Leute, die in der, in der Organisation des Events ihren Kopf dafür hinhalten, dass da nicht mehr Leute drin sind.
Und wenn dieser Punkt erreicht ist, müssen Absagen äh gegeben werden. Und ähm es gibt,
Vor diesem Hintergrund ist es völlig egal, auf welche Weise, nach welchem Prinzip wir diese Tickets verteilen. Ähm denn die Anzahl von Personen, die kein Ticket bekommen, wird immer gleich sein. Ähm.
Wir haben ja jetzt den Versuch gestartet mit diesem Token, wenigstens unsere langjährigen Teilnehmer äh und das, wo wir irgendwo Hacker-Community vermuten, ähm.
Eine Möglichkeit zu geben, sich vorher in diesen Vorverkauf zu beteiligen.
Aber es ist eben jetzt die Hälfte der Tickets in diesem freien Verkauf und ich denke, das ist eine faire, eine faire Verteilung und ich weiß,
ist ungerecht und das ist ärgerlich und wir werden viele Leute haben, die kein Ticket bekommen und jede einzelne Person ist zu Recht darüber frustriert,
Aber glaubt uns bitte, dass wir nicht äh diejenigen sind, die irgendwo sitzen und sich darüber Schrott lachen und euch das nicht gönnen. Für uns ist es.
Ebenso schmerzhaft,
und die die Art und Methode, wie wir die Tickets verteilen, ändert nichts an dieser Zahl. Zum Beispiel habe ich Beschwerden gehört darüber, dass wir äh den Vorverkauf in drei Anläufen machen, ja zu unterschiedlichen Tagen und Uhrzeiten. Ähm.
Oder eben gesagt wird, na ja, da damit äh verarscht er mich ja dreimal, bringt der mich dreimal in diese Situation, reißt das, pflastert doch lieber mit einem Ruck ab, ne? Gleichzeitig sind natürlich die Leute, die,
Einmal an so einem Vorverkauf teilnehmen und kein Ticket kriegen, verlangen dann mehr Chancen
ne? Sagen, gib mir doch mehr Chancen. Also wie du es machst, machst du es falsch und die Zahl derer, die kein Ticket bekommen ist immer exakt die gleiche, denn die ist durch das Kontingent bestimmt, was für einen Menschen äh da reinbringen können. Insofern wünsche ich allen, die das jetzt hören, die kein Ticket haben
Glück,
bei diesem, bei dieser letzten Phase des Vorverkaufs und alles, was ich dazu wirklich zu sagen habe, ist, dass wir alle, die diese Veranstaltung äh machen.
Mitleiden unter dieser Situation.
Es kam dann natürlich auch gleich wieder die äh Verschwörungstheorie auf, das würde ja nur deshalb gemacht werden, damit man unter sich bleibe. Das hört man äh dann auch oft.
Ja, du hast aber äh das auch genau das Gegenteil, ne? Also ich musste jetzt.
Ja, man hört alles Mögliche, nur um mal auch äh vielleicht zu den einzelnen äh Sichtweisen, was was zu sagen. Also erstmal ist äh Quatsch, meine wenn wir unter uns bleiben wollten, dann bräuchten wir diese Veranstaltung nicht zu machen, ja? Schon gar nicht in dieser Größe.
Der der Event ist dafür gedacht äh äh deutlich über ähm,
die Zahl von Leuten, mit denen man normalerweise im Jahr äh zu tun hat, hinauszugehen, auch äh ganz andere kulturelle ähm Bereiche zu erschließen, was in den letzten Jahren ja auch in zunehmendem Maße äh gelingt. Und auch die Entscheidung,
überhaupt größer zu werden, war im Prinzip schon eine Reaktion da drauf. Man erinnere sich vor fünf Jahren war dieses Limit bei dreitausend Leuten,
Mittlerweile haben wir die Hälfte der Tickets quasi im Umfeld verteilt, ja? Um einfach sicherzustellen, dass die Leute, die uns wirklich nahe stehen und die auch,
konkret sich für diesen Kongress einbringen und dort engeln und die einfach dieser Kongress auch sind, ja? Ähm dass dass die dabei sind und wir geben dann immer noch doppelt so viele Tickets raus, als wir insgesamt,
Vor ein paar Jahren überhaupt hatten. Ja? Also es bewegt sich in ganz anderen Dimensionen,
und es ist nicht unbedingt einfacher geworden, diesen Event zu organisieren, also äh allein das finanzielle Investitionsvolumen, um diese Veranstaltung zu wuppen, die liegt so dermaßen weit von dem,
entfernt, was was der Club in seiner Gänze vor.
Noch nicht mal zwanzig Jahren für vollkommen absurdes Risiko gehalten hätte, ja und mittlerweile hat sich das äh soweit normalisiert, dass,
dass wir in der Lage sind äh mal eben die größte Konferenz in Europa zu organisieren, was der Kongress im Übrigen ist, nicht die Größe Haka Konferenz, sondern die größte Konferenz,
ja irgendwann,
ist halt so ein Punkt erreicht, wo man versuchen muss, da eine Balance zu finden, aber es ist wirklich in jedermanns Interesse diese Balance auch zu finden.
Ähm.
Zu dieser zu dieser Geschichte, wir wollen äh nicht Nerds raushalten oder oder wollen sie nicht raushalten. Das ist also diese Theorie ist einfach abhängig davon, wer kein Ticket bekommen hat, ne? Also da wer noch kein Ticket hat. Also Leute, die
gerne hinwollen und sich nicht als Teil der Community begreifen, äh sagen dann, ja hier die Hacker äh schließen uns aus,
äh oder der der CTC igelt sich ein und dann hast du die anderen, die sagen
diese neuen da die neben mir das Ticket weg, der CCC der CC holt sich da jetzt irgendwie nicht Hacker rein,
können gar nicht,
ich hab versucht mit denen über Kompeiler Architektur zu sprechen und da kriegst du keine vernünftige Antwort, die gehören da nicht hin. Ähm, beides ist
natürlich ähm dann eher etwas zu belächeln,
Aber äh genau, das könnte ich für, wir haben äh es gab irgendwie so eine seltsame Situation auf Twitter, wo ähm,
Wo auch ein ein Hörer dieser dieser Sendung das angesprochen hat, dass du nicht mal gesagt hast, ähm.
Dass wir mit befremden beobachten, wer wer Interesse an an dieser Veranstaltung hätte oder so. Und das haben dann alle möglichen Leute wieder, ne? Auf auf sich bezogen.
Da da hat der Tim eigentlich eine Anspielung darauf gemacht, wenn dann so die Sekretärin eines größeren Unternehmens
anfragt in der Chefetage und dann mal gerne äh für zwanzig Tickets wüsste wo sie da denn jetzt irgendwie das Ei töten kann und wer denn die Hotelbuchung übernimmt. Wir hätten doch da dieses Hotel.
Mit wem man vor allem reden muss für den Messestand, ja? Also auch sowas gab's ja schon. Ja, ja, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo man denn dann seinen Stand aufbauen kann.
Ohne dass, also das ist ähm das ist eine der amüsantesten äh also wir kriegen dann äh regelmäßig so Anfragen nach äh den den Messestandpreisen
Also sollen bitte mal die Daten rüberschicken, so sie hätten größeren Stand vor und ähm wir sollen da mal bitte äh hier mit den Quadratmeterpreisen und so äh und wann, ab wann geht der Aufbau?
Professionelle Messe unter dem, die da einen Stand machen wollen.
Oder so Vögel, die dann so, ja, jetzt habe ich gar kein Ticket bekommen, ist ja ein großes Problem, weil äh ich habe ja äh meinen Kunden,
Ja, bereits irgendwelche Kurse versprochen, die dann da vor Ort abgehalten werden, wie soll ich denn das sonst einhalten, ja? Also das sind alles so äh äh Tendenzen, die im Vergleich zum Gesamtgeschehen noch
minor sind, also die die alle für sich genommen eigentlich noch Ausreißer sind, aber an der Stelle gilt auch, während den Anfängen. Äh da müssen wir natürlich auch zusehen
dass Leute, die überhaupt keine Ahnung haben, was dieser Event eigentlich ist und da auch nicht mit irgendeiner,
Hoffnung und und und mit der mit der ähm Hirneinstellung, die wir eigentlich uns wünschen, dort äh aufschlagen
dass wir die halt, na ja, also entweder besser informieren in dem Moment und vielleicht ist es ja doch äh das, was sie eigentlich gesucht haben.
Oder ihnen helfen, was anderes zu.
Ja oder einfach zu sagen so ja hör mal, also äh du brauchst eigentlich jetzt hier äh was ganz anderes und ähm
liegt da einfach falsch, eure Erwartungshaltung ist falsch und am Ende würde das äh nix bringen, ne. Wobei ich mir auch durchaus vorstellen kann, dass dann auch schon so von der Hypnis des Events äh gezogen
vielleicht auch schon sozusagen so ein bisschen so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein Geschenkgutschein sein kann, so. Ah ja, hier für unsere Mitarbeiter macht da mal richtig Spaß hier.
Gibt ganz viel und ich ich erlaube mir
also ich außer wenn es jetzt wirklich um klaren Kommerz geht und um vollständiges Verkennen diese diese Situation sich wieder wenig Urteil äh drüber erlauben, welche Leute jetzt zu der Veranstaltung kommen sollen und welche nicht. Wir haben da natürlich ein klares Bild, was diese Veranstaltung ist
Und diese Veranstaltung wird spricht ein bestimmtes Publikum an und ein bestimmtes eben nicht. Und ähm,
das lasse ich mir auch ungern vorhalten. Aber,
ich muss sagen, der Shitstorm hält sich auch in Grenzen. Es ist eher ein ein lautes äh gequältes Jaulen und wir wir sind mitten dabei, weil wir alle auch darunter leiden. Ähm.
Ansonsten kann ich glaube ich noch kurz bekanntgeben, dass das äh dass das offizielle Designpack äh äh gestern veröffentlicht wurde,
Woher weiß ich das? Ähm findet man auf Events CC DE einen kleinen Blogpost zu, in dem auch nochmal das Motto so ein bisschen
näher gebracht wird, ähm, was wir damit zum Ausdruck bringen und da kann man sich die Grafiken runterladen, die dies Jahr die
Stella angefertigt hat. Ähm.
Die äh ja einigen bekannt ist sicherlich von unseren Freunden beim Podcast technische Aufklärung und da sieht man mal wieder, was das alles für ein Sumpf ist. Drain this form, kann ich nur sagen. Drain the swarm.
Ja, der Sumpf ist jetzt trocken gelegt, oder?
Der so fistrock.
Ja ist das wohl wieder eine lange Sendung. Ja. Und ich dachte jetzt, wenn man irgendwie schon nach weniger als einer Woche an Start gehen, aber na ja, so ist das halt.
Ja demnächst äh machen wir wieder kürzer. Also nee, vor allem machen wir also wahrscheinlich werden die Sendungen jetzt wieder länger, weil wir seltener welche machen, weil Kongressstress und dann gibt's halt lange Sendungen. Beim Kongress machen wir keinen, oder?
Ich habe einen nicht, denke nicht.
Ich denke, unser Live äh Programmpotential für äh dieses Quartal ist äh es ist erfüllt, ja.
Live-Programm gibt's aber noch ähm wollen wir Musik machen.
Oh, Musik.
In Berlin vom fünfundzwanzigsten bis siebenundzwanzigsten elften findet die Fifcon statt unter dem Motto in Visibal Systems
In der TU Berlin im Mathegebäude und da gibt's echt ein ganz äh ausführliches Speaker Programm. Ähm,
Für Freitagabend meine persönliche Empfehlung Erich Möchel, neunzehn Uhr fünfzehn mit dem Cyber, der Start als Krimineller, aber dann haben wir da noch weitere Namen wie Jan Philipp Albrecht, Anna Biselli
und weitere
Illustrussprecher aus diesem ganzen Netzumfeld, unter anderem auch Klaus Landefeld. Ein weiterer, wo ich auch mal beklagen, äh den wir bei der LP zweihundert gerne gehabt hätten, der aber leider nicht konnte. Konstanze kurz ist dabei ähm
Wolfgang Kreu, da gibt's eine ganze Menge zu sehen. Gabi Weber sogar, ja, über drei Tage geht diese Veranstaltung in Berlin und Tickets,
Gützig ist kostenlos. Also ich glaube, er muss.
Ist doch nichts wert.
Äh Wahnsinn. Also echt irre, was da äh was da aufgefahren wurde, kann ich nur empfehlen.
Gut. Dann äh denke ich mal, kommen wir dann wirklich.
Wobei ich nicht genau weiß, vielleicht muss man sich da doch anmelden. Ich wäre jetzt nicht, vielleicht muss man sich da anmelden. Ja, da steht Anmeldung oben auf der Website.
Ach so, da muss man vielleicht.
Ja Anwärter gut hier. Anmeldung ist kostenfrei. Ja gut, also.
Wollen halt noch deine Daten sam.
Das ist ja wie beim CTC Vorverkauf.
Tja.
Skandal. Okay, ich merke, wir werden albern.
Sehr. Ja, willkommen zum Ende der Sendung sage ich mal. Ja. Aber so sehr viel mehr haben wir jetzt nicht zu sagen. Außer ähm tschüss, oder?
Ciao, ciao. Bis dahin, nächstes Mal und so weiter.
Genau, hier ist immer und so weiter.